côté pour le gouvernement d'avoir
recours au PS sanitaire jusqu'au 28
février dans la version du texte des
sénateurs ou le 31 juillet tel que
souhaiterait voir adopter le
gouvernement ainsi que les députés la
séance va reprendre d'un instant à
l'autre au nom je vous parle les
sénateurs et la ministre madame
bourguignon sont en train de s'installer
la discussion générale s'est arrêtée
avant la pose déjeuner après à la prise
de parole des deux corps importants
ainsi que de la ministre il reste la
prise de parole de tous les groupes
politiques qui vont venir à la tribune
pour donner leur opinion de ce texte
puis on aura la discussion des articles
et des amendements au moment où je vous
parle le président de sciences est en
train de bien faire le chemin qui arrive
jusqu'à l'hémicycle avec vous le savez
sur ce texte trois différences majeures
entre la version que voudrais voir
adopter les sénateurs et celle du
gouvernement notamment sur la question
de la date on l'a dit également sur la
question de la territorialisation
possible et on va voir un débat en
séance sur cette mesure de la
territorialisation qui a fait en
commission et enfin troisième mesure sur
laquelle il n'y a pas d'accord entre
sénateurs et députés c'est sur la
possibilité pour les chefs
d'établissement de contrôler la
vaccination des élèves et donc et bien
je vous propose d'aller dans l'hémicycle
puisque cette séance est en train de
commencer tout de suite puisque la
cloche à retentit
du projet de loi portant diverses
dispositions de vigilance sanitaires
dans la discussion de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 8 minutes
ce président madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mes chers collègues
le Parlement est donc appelé à se
prononcer sur le texte relatif à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire dans un
calendrier à peu près normal pour une
fois ce qui n'était pas le cas des cas
précédentes et surtout de la dernière
puisque nous avons eu moins de 7 jours
entre l'adoption en conseil des
ministres et la fin de la navette ce qui
a été quand même une triste performance
vous nous avez exposé madame la ministre
la situation sanitaire du pays et si
nous ne pourrons pas encore dire que
l'épidémie est derrière nous nous
pouvons nous réjouir de la traînette
amélioration observée depuis l'été je
voudrais quand même nous et nous
rappeler et vous rappeler qu'il y a
presque un an jour pour jour le 29
octobre nous entamons le deuxième
confinement il faut quand même pas
l'oublier nous revenons de loin si j'ose
dire dans dans cette matière nos
concitoyens sont massivement tournés
vers la vaccination largement incitée
par la généralisation du Pass sanitaire
et c'est tant mieux la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui est en étant la
situation sanitaire en novembre de 2021
le Parlement doit-il continuer de
conférer au gouvernement des pouvoirs
exorbitants du droit commun pour gérer
la crise et si oui jusque quand rarement
un débat n'a été aussi hystérisé passe
de la honte passe de la ségrégation
utilisation des symboles de l'étoile
jaune des milliers d'e-mails madame
ministre des milliers d'e-mails jusqu'à
saturer l'ensemble de nos boîtes mails
des menaces sur les parlementaires y
compris physiques je n’ai pas j'ai pas
de mémoire j'ai pas de souvenirs d'un
débat aussi hystérisé sur cette sur
cette question pour pour le grand public
j'ai tendance à penser que cette
question prend une forme simplifiée
droite on doit-on prolonger le Pass
sanitaire l'outil le plus tangible ce
cette gestion de crise plusieurs de mes
collègues étaient sont toujours au
stylopass tout en étant très clairement
favorable à la vaccination mais une
large majorité des sénateurs sont
tristes a adhéré à l'extension de son
usage juillet dernier maintenant que la
population est largement vaccinée je
dois dire que nous sommes plus nombreux
à être réticents à le voir prolongé le
gouvernement a répété à de nombreuses
reprises que lorsque le Pass sanitaire
ne serait plus utile il serait supprimé
nous ne doutons pas de sa bonne foi mais
on constate dans les faits que l'usage
du Pass sanitaire est entré dans notre
quotidien et pourrait se prolonger
pendant encore des mois le gouvernement
ne nous donne pas à ce stade les
critères qui permettraient d'exon de
s'exonérer du pass ou de tout outil
dérogatoire au droit commun dont il
dispose aujourd'hui il est légitime
madame la ministre de s'interroger sur
le retour aux droits communs
la réponse consistant à dire dès que
nous n'aurons plus besoin du Pass nous
serons ravis de le supprimer n'est pas
suffisante et pour les plus jeunes
d'entre nous ça ressemble un peu à
l'affaire et l'histoire de Fernand
Raynaud avec le fût du canon evidemment
pour refroidir il prend un certain temps
donc il faudrait pas que ce soit un
certain temps pour supprimer il faudrait
qu'on ait quand même non pas un horizon
comme vous l'avez dit mais enfin une
limite et c'est ce que va faire notre
commission des lois notre commission des
lois largement amorcée le travail et je
salue évidemment le travail remarquable
notre de notre rapporteur il nous
propose une
absolument normand et il nous propose
une date de sortie
s'appuyant à titre principal sur le taux
de vaccination notre commission des lois
a entendu exclure le Pass dès que ce
taux dépasserait 75 % de la population
concernée et bien la ministre la date du
31 juillet n'est pas acceptable pour
nous et nous la refusons
en adoptant cette logique on pourrait
même aller plus loin notre commission
propose donc de fixer la fin du régime
au 28 février et nous soutenons cette
date elle est respectueuse des principes
du Parlement elle est raisonnable et
pour ceux qui en douteraient le
Parlement peut être convoqué n'importe
quand à partir du 22 février jusque
jusqu'à la fin de la période électorale
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir ce délai qui
qui ressemble un peu à une roulette
russe parce que imaginons que le nouveau
président dont évidemment
ne connaît pas le nom ou la présidente
ils ont imaginons que les pouvoirs qu'on
donne aujourd'hui soit entre les mains
de monsieur Zemmour ou de Madame Le Pen
je suis pas très sûr que ce soit une
opération très rassurante donc le
gouvernement nous rassurera sans doute
avec des promesses de rapport les
rapports c'est bien mais le vote de la
représentation nationale nous semble
préférable le Parlement et le Sénat en
particulier a toujours répondu présent
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire y
compris lorsqu'il a dû délibérer dans
l'urgence absolue nous comptons donc
continuer à exercer pleinement notre
mission de législateur et de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement le Sénat
refusera je le répète de jouer à la
roulette russe avec des mesures
d'urgence globalement nous sommes
convaincus par l'objectif recherché même
si nous sommes plusieurs réservés sur le
principe de la territorisation qui d'un
point de vue théorique est une bonne
idée mais d'un point de vue pratique
avec des départements limit qui pourrait
ou ne pas être touchés par ce problème
de la territorialisation je pense que
dans la pratique ça posera évidemment un
certain nombre de questions et que nous
pourrons évidemment en débattre dans le
cadre du débat qui arrive on pourrait
prendre Paris et sa banlieue la scène
Saint-Denis serait toujours sous le pas
sanitaire alors que Paris ne le serait
pas je pense que la gestion au quotidien
de cette retiralisation pourrait
évidemment poser un certain nombre de
difficultés un mot sur l'article 4ter
article qui porte de notre point de vue
une atteinte grave au secret médical
lorsqu'on parle des mineurs il est
absolument contestable de porter
atteinte au secret médical je pense que
notre rapporteur s'en est ouvert
largement tout à l'heure et pour
conclure Madame la ministre je voudrais
rappeler comme vous l'avez fait
l'importance des mesures barrières on a
senti ici ou là
maintenant les activités dans nos
départements qu'il y avait un
relâchement certain voire un certain
relâchement je pense qu'une des clés du
maintien de la réduction du taux de
malade c'est aussi les mesures barrières
je pense qu'il est extrêmement important
de rappeler l'impérius nécessité de ces
mesures barrières qui vous l'avez dit et
je pense qu'on est tous à le constater
sont quand même un peu passés de mode et
je crois qu'il faut vraiment les
rétablir vous avez dit qu'il y aurait
une je crois une campagne
des médias sur les médias je pense que
c'est une très très bonne idée nous ne
sommes pas du tout sortis de cette crise
et il ne faut surtout pas encore une
fois retomber dans des travers qui
étaient les nôtres il y a quelques temps
et se rappeler comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'il y a juste un an jour pour
jour nous étions de nouveau
confinés il ne faudrait pas réduire
évidemment à néant les efforts qu'on
fait les Français à titre personnel et
au titre de contribuables parce que
cette crise nous a coûté très cher nous
allons le voir dans quelques semaines
sous ses réserves une partie du groupe
de l'Union centriste vautra le texte de
la commission des lois et une autre
partie votera contre je vous remercie de
votre attention merci chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à Madame Maryse Carrère pour le
groupe RDSE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
chers collègues nous voilà donc une fois
de plus réunis pour ce qui est
malheureusement devenu un marronnier de
l'activité parlementaire un texte sur
l'urgence sanitaire le 11e depuis mars
2020 de quoi toujours interroger sur
notre État de droit lorsque sur ces 6
dernières années nous en avons passé
trois sous un régime d'exception
si leur mise en place est toujours
justifiée leurs différentes
prolongations prouvent la difficulté que
nous avons à passer de l'urgence à sa
gestion aujourd'hui il faut s'en réjouir
nous ne sommes plus au pic de cette
crise une part plus que significative de
la population de plus de 12 ans et
vaccinée et surtout le vaccin fait ses
preuves en réduisant significativement
les risques de contamination et les cas
graves la pression hospitalière se fait
donc plus faible aussi je comprends que
l'on puisse s'interroger sur l'utilité
des dispositifs liés à la gestion de
cette crise en disant cela je ne nie pas
le risque de rebond épidémique qui je le
sais persiste malgré la vaccination mais
je veux interroger l’intérêt qu'il y a à
voter des prorogations de manière
systématique et pour des durées toujours
plus longues
d'autant qu'un métropole du moins il
n'est plus nécessaire de confiner et les
couvre-feu ont été levés mais ils
demeure parmi les dispositifs utilisés
l'un des plus controversés je pense au
Pass sanitaire il est d'autant plus
controversé qu'en avril dernier le
président de la République déclaré que
ce Pass sanitaire ne serait jamais un
droit d'accès qui différencie les
Français qui ne sauraient être
obligatoire pour accéder au lieu de vie
de tous les jours comme le restaurant
théâtre et cinéma nous le savons
maintenant le scénario ne s'est pas
déroulé exactement comme annoncé et au
contraire le pass a été largement
utilisé
bien entendu il faut dire qu'il fut dans
une certaine mesure une réussite d'abord
comme un témoigne les chiffres de
l'épidémie il a permis de surmonter
l'état d'urgence et de lutter contre
l'épidémie durant la période estivale
mais surtout il a participé à engager
avec force la campagne vaccinale qui
peinait à s'installer dans notre pays
seulement au regard du contexte
sanitaire et de l'avancée de la
vaccination se passe n'apparaît plus
comme un élément absolument essentiel et
un nouveau risque court celui de la de
sa banalisation de notre accoutumance à
un mécanisme que nous n'imaginions pas
possible avant la crise covid
aussi il apparaît nécessaire de
travailler à sortir des dispositifs
d'exception cela c'est d'ailleurs
traduit par un premier amendement adopté
contre la vie d'un rapporteur et du
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
permettant que le Pass ne puisse plus
s'appliquer lorsque le taux d'incidence
est inférieur ou égal à 50 %.000 dans un
département cela se traduit une nouvelle
fois à travers le dispositif reposé par
notre rapporteur Philippe Bas un ouvrant
la voie de la territorialisation il
permettra une gestion de la crise au
plus près des réalités du terrain et
viendra apaiser certaines
incompréhensions
si certaines dans notre groupe restent
fondamentalement opposés au passes
sanitaires ces aménagements sont de
nature à rassurer d'autres enfin il
demeure une question essentielle celle
de la date la majorité de notre groupe
avait aussi un amendement déposer en
commission par notre président
Jean-Claude Ruquier ramenant la
prorogation des différents régimes
d'exception à la date du 15 février 2022
nous nous satisfaisons donc de celles
retenues par notre rapporteur du 28
février 2022 il faut espérer qu'un
consensus soit possible sur cette
question nos instituts nos institutions
doivent pouvoir s'entendre sur des
sujets aussi graves et ne pas montrer
leur division et leur dispersion
notamment à quelques mois d'une période
électorale majeure où les populismes les
plus nausées à bons devront être
combattues aussi vous comprendrez que le
texte présenté initialement par le
gouvernement avait conduit à ce qu'une
majorité des membres du groupe RDSE
soient contre néanmoins les aménagements
qui lui ont été apportées ont conduit à
ce qu'un certain nombre d'entre il soit
finalement favorable cela étant chacun
se décidera suivant la liberté de vote
qui caractérise le RDSE je vous remercie
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Ravier pour les groupes des non
inscrits pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues après 20 mois
d'impréparation d'erreurs de mensonges
j'ai découvert cette nuit que le
gouvernement avait radicalement changé
l'orientation après l'annonce tant
attendue de la démission du ministre de
la Santé le Parlement décide dans enfin
dans unir avec le Pass sanitaire au 15
novembre et fait sauter l'obligation
vaccinale tout comme celle du port du
masque l'état d'urgence permanent qui
nous est imposé depuis 18 mois avec une
infligeante docilité parlementaire est
enfin abandonnée pour lutter contre les
résidences de la maladie le traitement
et la prise en charge du covid long sont
actées la recherche sur un traitement
les privilégié en même temps que nous
soutiendrons les vaccins français la
chaîne industrielle nationale et
indépendante en fin d'assurer un
approvisionnement sans pénurie et
désormais une priorité les moyens
humains en contrôle aux frontières pour
mieux contenir les résurgences sont
débloqués après des années de sa cage de
l'hôpital public un grand plan pour nos
hôpitaux et nos personnels soignants
sera présenté par le nouveau ministre de
la Santé dans la journée l'application
coûteuse est dangereuse tous anti covid
et les contrôles numériques sont
proscrits les verbalisations les tests
payants abandonnés le chef du
gouvernement annonce même je le cite
nous avons écouté nous avons entendu le
peuple français ainsi la loi redevient
légitime orienté vers l'unité du peuple
et le bien commun les visages les
sourires le contact la simplicité la
confiance l'esprit de voisinage et de
communauté sont de retour la France est
de retour je n'ai pu mes chers collègues
retenir un large sourire de satisfaction
en même temps que couler sur mes joues
des larmes d'émotion
et puis et puis mon réveil a sonné et je
me suis réveillé de ce retour à la
liberté n'est nullement question le
Parlement est toujours aussi docile et
Laos vice sanitaire sera j'en ai bien
peur reconduit le chantage à la
vaccination et confirmé son corollaire
du tout contrôle généralisé le secret
médical levé avec pour conséquence une
fracture entre les citoyens plus grand
encore le seul le seul qui soit sur la
sellette ce n'est pas le ministre de la
Santé qui se sera trompé ou qui aura
menti depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire non le seul sur lequel les
pouvoirs publics et pharmaceutiques
s'acharnent aujourd'hui c'est le
professeur Raoult s'est tiréductible
Gaulois c'est irréductible Gaulois de la
médecine qui aura commis le crime le
seul crime de soigner à un coup
dérisoire il est aujourd'hui lâché par
ses élus dont je tiré le nom
mais alors qu'ils étaient atteints du
covid ce sont précipités alliage de
Marseille pour bénéficier du traitement
de celui qu'il traîne aujourd'hui dans
la boue en les écoutant l'on ressent le
besoin urgent de traitement contre la
nausée ces libertés retrouvées n'étaient
donc un rêve un songe d'une nuit
d'automne il ne tient pourtant qu'à nous
mes chers collègues de lui donner
réalité c'est l'alsoir de la France et
des Français puissiez vous enfin les
écouter
si chers collègues dans la suite de la
discussion la parole est à Madame
Marie-Pierre de la gontrée pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste républicain
pour 9 minutes
monsieur le monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues je voudrais d'abord regretter
l'absence du ministre de la Santé je le
dis à Madame bourguignon qui est nous
nous connaissons depuis longtemps je
l'apprécie elle le sait indépendamment
de ses évolutions politiques n'empêche
que
significatif que aujourd'hui dans un
débat aussi important le ministre de la
santé n'est pas considéré de voir être
présent
pour la 11e fois en 20 mois nous nous
apprêtons donc à examiner un texte
visant à faire face à la crise sanitaire
et pour la 11e fois l'exécutif pousse un
examen à la hâte d'un texte qui pourtant
touche au cœur de nos libertés publiques
et de nos droits les plus fondamentaux
ce qui pouvait au début de la pandémie
se justifier par l'urgence peine
aujourd'hui à s'expliquer soit par un
manque d'anticipation soit par un
absence une absence de considération du
rôle du Parlement et mon propos
liminaire il faisait référence que
proposez-vous de la part du gouvernement
rien de moins que de prolonger jusqu'à
l'été 2022 c'est-à-dire au-delà de la
fin de ce quinquennat le cadre juridique
permettant de déclarer l'urgence
sanitaire et où le régime transitoire en
vigueur aujourd'hui
parce qu'il dessaisit le Parlement pour
une durée au-delà de l'acceptable parce
qu'il impose pour une durée
exceptionnelle excessive au regard de la
nécessité ce projet de loi porte
atteinte au bon fonctionnement de notre
démocratie pourquoi faudrait-il proroger
l'état d'urgence pour si longtemps la
tenue d'élection aussi essentielle pour
notre démocratie soit-elle ne peut pas
être un motif valable rappelons que le
Parlement peut toujours être réuni à
tout moment si besoin et quand bien même
nous ne partageions pas les orientations
du gouvernement nous avons toujours fait
preuve de notre capacité de réaction et
de mobilisation et nous avons largement
prouvé notre capacité à voter un tel
régime dans une temporalité très courte
en mars 2020 vous vous en rappelez nous
l'avons fait dans des conditions que
l'on pourrait qualifier d'extrême en
plein confinement et la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui n'est plus la même
le taux d'incidence est désormais
inférieur au premier seuil d'alerte dans
presque tous les départements la
covid-19 est désormais partie de notre
quotidien je reprends d'ailleurs
l'argument très juste de mon collègue
Bernard gemier qui lors de l'audition le
ministre de la Santé mardi indiquait que
si le virus reste à un stade de bruit de
fond avec des résurgences cycliques
notre système de santé était en mesure
de le prendre en charge comme les virus
saisonniers que nous connaissons bien et
donc parfois nous oublions un peu vite
la dangerosité comme par exemple la
grippe aussi si nous devons apprendre à
vivre durablement avec le virus nous
devons le faire dans un régime de droit
commun nous ne pouvons accepter de
prolonger aussi durablement un régime
d'exception qui atteint profondément
l'État de droit nous pouvons accepter de
nous habituer à vivre dans une société
de restriction de liberté il nous
apparaît au contraire nécessaire de nous
interroger régulièrement vu de la
situation et de savoir si ces
restrictions sont toujours justifiées ou
non ces questionnements n'ont pas manqué
de traverser les rangs même de la
majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée
nationale je pense évidemment à
l'amendement du député lrem pas comme
rupin adopté en commission qui proposait
des circonscrire l'utilisation du Pass
sanitaire au département dans le taux
d'incidence du virus dépassé habitants
par semaine mais au-delà soulignons que
ce projet de loi n'a été adopté qu'une
très courte majorité de dix voix à
l'Assemblée nationale à cet égard les
modifications apportées à l'initiative
du rapporteur de la commission des lois
et adoptée par cette commission vont
plutôt dans le bon sens même si pour
notre groupe elles sont imparfaites
elles ont pour mérite de limiter dans le
temps les mesures d'exception et de
conduire ainsi le gouvernement à revenir
vers le Parlement en cas de nécessité
elle pose toutefois des critères au
maintien d'outils tels que le Pass
sanitaire qui ne nous semble pas
satisfaisant et sur lequel nous
proposerons des amendements car
maintenir le Pass sanitaire est-il
pertinent je rappelle que dès son
instauration le gouvernement avait
affirmé qu'il n'était justifié que le
temps de la vaccination or près de 50
millions de nos concitoyens sont
désormais vaccinés de plus cet outil qui
a pu avoir un effet d'obligation
vaccinale masqué semble avoir perdu de
cet effet au regard de la constante
diminution des doses quotidiennes
injectées depuis mi-septembre moins de
25000 par jour
le Pass sanitaire ne représente donc
plus aujourd'hui ce levier efficace pour
vacciner le reste de la population
éligible se pose alors la question
légitime de la prolongation d'un
dispositif qui a épuisé son effet
d'incitation à la vaccination qui
présente une faible et qui signification
virale et pose par ailleurs de réels
problèmes sur le plan des libertés
publiques nous proposerons donc
paramendement dans quelques instants
qu'au-delà de 80% de couverture au sein
de la population éligible dans un
département de personnes vaccinées le
Pass sanitaire ne trouve plus à
s'appliquer ce qui inclurait d'ores et
déjà l'ensemble du territoire de la
métropole nous avons bien entendu
pleinement conscience que à ce jour la
situation sanitaire en outre-mer ne
permet pas de mettre fin aux mesures
d'exception que ces territoires
connaissent à défaut nous proposerons
plusieurs aménagements qui permettront
de prendre en compte dès maintenant
l'amélioration notable de la situation
la prise en compte du taux d'incidence
sur 7 jours ou encore la fin du Pass
sanitaire en extérieur
notre objectif est toujours le même
celui d'une vaccination universelle
solution que le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale ont rejeté en
juillet et en octobre et qui pourtant la
seule solution claire durable et
transparentes il est dès lors de la
responsabilité de gouvernement du
gouvernement de trouver les moyens de
convaincre les plus réticents de se
faire vacciner et de conduire une
éventuelle campagne de rappel campagne
qui sont même avoir commencé pour une
partie de notre population bien que
certains arbitrages se fassent toujours
attendre le Pass sanitaire intégrale
intégrera-t-il cette dose de rappel
sera-t-elle obligatoire pour les
soignants à ce jour le ministre n'est
pas capable de répondre sur ces
différents sujets le gouvernement peine
à donner des réponses précises à
rétablir un climat de confiance tente
avec la représentation nationale qu'avec
les Français
notre groupe s'oppose également à la
disposition introduite par le
gouvernement lors de l'examen du texte à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui autorise
les chefs d'établissement du primaire et
du secondaire à connaître le statut
virologique et vaccinal de leurs élèves
la Commission a fait le choix de sa
suppression et c'est heureux le Sénat
c'était d'ailleurs déjà opposé en
juillet dernier à cette même mesure que
par ailleurs ni les chefs
d'établissement ni les parents d'élèves
ne souhaitent et qui pose de graves
problèmes en matière d'atteinte au
secret médical mes chers collègues
encore une fois la méthode n'est pas à
la hauteur du débat que mérite les
Français et le contenu du texte soulève
bien plus d'inquiétudes qui n'ont
soulage alors même que la situation
sanitaire nous laisse entrevoir un
retour prochain un avis normal nous
vivons avec cette pandémie depuis
maintenant de nombreux mois même si tout
le monde en est un peu lassé le port du
masque les gestes barrières et les
mesures visant à freiner la propagation
de l'épidémie sont pourtant toujours
largement acceptés et suivi et pendant
ce temps la couverture vaccinale a
beaucoup progressé la lutte contre
l'iPad pandémie va dorénavant s'ins dans
un temps extrêmement long le moment est
largement venu de retrouver nos libertés
fondamentales et de renouer avec l'État
de droit c'est un enjeu pour notre
démocratie pour la République la
position du groupe socialiste est claire
nous refusons d'accorder un blanc simple
pour une période enjambant deux
élections nationales majeures toute
restriction des libertés doit relever de
la seule compétence du Parlement en cela
nous partageons l'analyse de rapporteur
de la commission des lois qui vient de
le manifester de manière expressive nous
partageons également le refus de voir
les directeurs d'école connaître le
statut vaccinal de ses élèves
nous refusons la prolongation de toute
forme de passes sanitaire dans les
territoires où il n'est plus nécessaire
nous refusons de maintenir plus que de
raison un état d'exception aussi en
l'état nous ne pourrons pas voter pour
ce texte pour toutes les raisons que
nous avons évoquées même si les
améliorations de la commission sont
notables nous réservons notre vote au
sort qui sera fait de nos propositions
d'amendements
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion la parole est à Monsieur
Martin lévrier pour le groupe RDP pour 6
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame et Monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur et madame
le rapporteur mes chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur vous l'avez bien
dit nous sommes retrouvés 11 fois depuis
le début de cette pandémie jamais un
Parlement européen n'avait autant été si
sollicité c'est bien la démonstration
que gouvernement est toujours à l'écoute
de nos deux chambres vous l'avez dit
aussi notre compréhension notre analyse
et les outils en notre possession on
considérablement évolué depuis mars 2020
et c'est aussi pour cela que nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui avec des mesures
bien moins restrictives que le
couvre-feu ou le confinement nul ne nira
par exemple que le Pass sanitaire a fait
ses preuves
déposez le 13 octobre 21 le projet de
loi portant divers dispositions de
vigilance sanitaires vivent à proroger
le régime de sortie de crise sanitaire
donnant au gouvernement la faculté de
mobiliser une gamme d'outils de gestion
de la crise sanitaire si la situation
l'exigeait y compris de manière
territorialisée territorialisée pardon
ceux sous le contrôle du juge et celui
renforcé lors de l'examen à l'Assemblée
nationale du Parlement le texte prévoit
notamment le report au 31 juillet 2022
de la fin du cadre juridique de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire fixé aujourd'hui au
31 décembre 2021 la prorogation jusqu'au
31 juillet 2022 du régime de gestion de
sortie de crise sanitaire et la
possibilité de mobiliser par voie
réglementaire le Pass sanitaire ainsi
que le renforcement de la fraude au Pass
sanitaire la facilitation du contrôle de
l'obligation vaccinale et le
renforcement de son effectivité enfin la
progression de plusieurs mesures
accompagnement pour faire face aux
conséquences de la crise sanitaire
relative notamment au dispositifs
d'activités partielles monsieur le
rapporteur je lis dans la presse depuis
plusieurs jours que l'issue du vote au
Sénat est décidé je n'en prends pas acte
et plus encore que cette issu serait
fondé sur une juste adaptation à la
situation épidémiologique du pays cette
situation il faut en parler après huit
semaines de baisse consécutives le taux
d'incidence a augmenté de 10% pendant la
semaine de 10 au 17 octobre conséquence
le pays a dépassé le seuil d'alerte de
54 pour 100000 habitants le nombre de
nouvelles contaminations quotidienne a
quant à lui franchi la barre symbolique
des 5000 cas depuis trois jours et à
l'approche de l'hiver les
épidémiologistes gardent tous les yeux
rivés sur les courbes nous devons
collectivement faire de même
pour autant 7 millions de Français ne
sont pas encore convaincus et si en
France les voyants virent à l'orange
comme le titre libération hier la carte
de l'Europe quant à elle se colore de
rouge le nombre de cas de covid-19
recensés chaque jour a augmenté d'une
semaine à l'autre dans la quasi-totalité
des pays du continent la tendance est
générale plus 37,2 en Italie plus 48,5
en Allemagne plus 57 en Autriche avec
des pointes à 95 en Pologne et même plus
de 120% en République tchèque à ce la
s’ajoute la contagiosité accrue du
variant Delta le ralentissement de la
progression de la couverture vaccinale
la baisse progressive de l'efficacité de
la protection du vaccin au cours du
temps en particulier chez les personnes
âgées première cible de la campagne
enfin la possibilité d'une émergence de
nouveaux variants avec des facteurs de
risque plus importants ou une moindre
sensibilité au vaccin disponible
regardons le Royaume-Uni et son nouveau
sous variant qui nous invite à une
nouvelle vigilance nos voisins
outre-manches comptabilisent 150 000
nouveaux cas par jour les scientifiques
prévoient une persistance du risque de
rebond jusqu'à l'été 2022 au moins
justifiant les géants les échéances
proposées par le texte initial c'était
de fait appel au maintien des
dispositifs éprouvés et opérants or en
application du texte de la commission
non seulement les mesures de freinage
seraient réagencées dans une
architecture bien complexe mais le Pass
sanitaire ne pourrait plus être mis en
oeuvre dans les départements dépensant
dépassant un taux de vaccination de 75%.
faut-il rappeler que plus de 75% de la
population du Royaume-Uni et vacciné
voilà pour les chiffres et il n'y a pas
que les chiffres pensons au personnels
soignants épuisés par le travail
extraordinaire de mené depuis deux ans
il réclame de la stabilité et de la
clarté dans les mesures proposées
changer de fusil d'épaule juste avant la
saison hivernale ou dans quatre mois ne
le rendrait pas service ce texte doit va
nous permettre d'accélérer encore la
vaccination et gardons au-delà et
regardons au-delà de nos frontières en
Allemagne des Landers autorisent
désormais des restaurateurs et des
exploitants de lieux culturels à refuser
les non vaccinés bien que tester négatif
en Autriche si la situation s'aggrave
seuls les habitants non vaccinés
pourraient faire l'objet d'un
confinement que dire de la Chine qui
reconfine 4 millions de ses habitants
personne en France ne souhaite en
arriver là non il ne s'agit pas
d'accoutumance mais de prévention non il
ne s'agit pas de donner un blanc sain au
gouvernement mais de lui conférer
l'agilité nécessaire pour faire face à
une pandémie qui a mis à genoux le monde
entier il s'agit de s'adapter à la
rapidité avec laquelle le virus continue
de nous surprendre au même titre que la
chambre haute a su s'adapter à plusieurs
reprises en prolongeant certaines
mesures efficientes sans pour autant les
pérenniser je pense notamment au texte
de mai et d'août 2021 sur le quai un
accord avait été trouvé vous compris mes
chers collègues notre groupe soutient le
projet de loi tel qu'il nous arrive de
l'Assemblée nationale il provoquent des
dispositifs validés par le Conseil
constitutionnel et éprouvé dans la
gestion de crise et en renforce les
garanties notre groupe ne s'inscrira pas
dans la version ici de la commission des
Lois du Sénat dont la temperalité et la
complexité nuira à la clarté et à
l'efficacité pourtant indispensable à
cette période de pandémie je vous
remercie merci chers collègues dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Claude Malhuret
pour les indépendants pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je suppose
que vos boîtes mails ont été une fois de
plus envahies comme la mienne par les
milliers de spams envoyés par les
antivax les antipasses les plus
généralement les Antilles tout ce qui
bougent Robert Kennedy avait l'habitude
de dire 20 % des gens sont contre-tout
tout le temps je voudrais commencer par
dire à ces trolls que les campagnes de
spam déclenchent chez moi une réaction
quasi réflexe l'envie de voter dans le
sens opposé à ce qu'ils demandent ou
plutôt qu'ils exigent et je ne pense pas
être le seul la quatrième vague due aux
variant Delta 3 fois plus contagieux que
la souche initiale régresse depuis deux
mois grâce à trois mesures la
vaccination massive le respect des
gestes barrières et le Pass sanitaire
la France est aujourd'hui l'un des pays
peut être le pays au monde le mieux
vacciné et cela lui permet d'être dans
une situation très enflable même si elle
reste fragile nous savons désormais que
le vaccin réduit de 92% le risque
d'hospitalisation chez les plus de 50
ans ce chiffre pas fini de déconsidérer
ce qui depuis des mois tente de
discréditer la vaccination la
vaccination a fait ses preuves le Pass
sanitaire aussi nous allons donc
débattre des modalités de prolongation
du Pass sanitaire et non du passe
lui-même il est autorisé jusqu'au 15
novembre c'est-à-dire dans 15 jours et
la grande majorité de cette assemblée
n'a aucunement l'intention de le
supprimer pour l'heure l'épidémie n'est
pas finie elle flambe à nouveau chez nos
voisins et tous les scientifiques
s'attendent à une recrudescence
hivernale ne pas prolonger le Pass
serait une erreur majeure dans des
plaies à ceux qui défilent au nom des
libertés bafouées la plupart des
Français le comprennent et l'acceptent
ils savent que les quelques désagréments
du Pass sont peu de choses par rapport à
un reconfinement si la situation devait
s'aggraver ils ont bien saisi que le
Pass n'est pas un outil de contrainte
mais de liberté le gouvernement demande
au Parlement deux choses la première est
de prolonger jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022
l'autorisation que nous lui avons donné
de remettre en place l'état d'urgence
sanitaire en de nécessité cette
prolongation n'excende pas le
gouvernement de demander la vie du
Parlement dans les quatre semaines il
n'y a donc pas dans ce cas de
décaisissement des prérogatives du
Parlement la deuxième est celle qui pose
problème elle permet de prolonger
plusieurs mesures et notamment le Pass
sanitaire sans validation par le
Parlement avant le 31 juillet la
Commission souhaite une clause de
revoyure peut-on sans dessaisir le
Parlement de ses prérogatives donner un
blanc sain de plusieurs mois au
gouvernement il y a des arguments en ce
sens le premier est la suspension des
travaux du Parlement pendant quatre mois
à partir du 28 février le deuxième est
en février liminant de l'élection
présidentielle risque de transformer en
pugilat un débat qui devrait rester
technique le troisième est que le
conseil il est à juge les libertés ne
voit pas d'objection il estime je cite
que la prorogation envisagée n'est pas
contraire à la protection des libertés
fondamentales enfin le Conseil
Scientifique la prouve aussi disant je
cite
il perçoit la nécessité opérationnelle
de cette durée compte tenu de la
persistance des risques potentiels
jusqu'au 31 juillet ces arguments ont du
poids mais nous sommes des
parlementaires jaloux à juste titre de
nos prérogatives et toujours réticents
lorsqu'il s'agit des libertés à nous en
dessaisir pour de longues périodes
j'étais donc partagé sur ce sujet
je ne le suis plus depuis que j'ai pris
connaissance du texte issu de la
commission qui ne me paraît pas
satisfaisant d'abord il est devenu
illisible je ne suis pas le premier à le
dire il y avait deux régimes celui de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et celui de
la sortie de crise il y aura désormais
ces deux-là jusqu'au 15 novembre et de
nouveau ensuite qui ne porte pas de nom
et qui comporte des mesures voisines
mais non identiques sans que les raisons
n'en apparence clairement il y aura
aussi une territorialisation du Pass
sanitaire sur des critères rigides et
discutables qui rendra son implication
différente d'un département à l'autre ce
sera une usine à gaz enfin la date du 28
février me paraît une opportune le
déchenon de passion aujourd'hui sur ce
débat à l'Assemblée sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans la rue comme hier et
aujourd'hui encore en face du Sénat avec
une sono de 15000 watts par ceux qui se
prennent pour la France libre ne
laissent hélas que trop pouvoir prévoir
en février à un mois d'élection
présidentielle que nous discuterons de
tout sauf des mesures contre épidémie
enfin nous avons besoin d'une réponse
rapide en cas de nouvelles flambées en
juin dernier c'est l'intervention
immédiate du président de la République
décidant du Pass sanitaire devant
l'explosion de l'épidémie qui a permis
l'adhésion de tous les Français avec 6
nations en cas d'un nouveau rebond et de
la nécessité de généraliser dans
l'urgence la troisième dose ou d'autres
mesures est-ce que nous allons attendre
de réunir l'Assemblée nationale puis le
Sénat qui auront alors suspendu les
travaux chez la plupart de nos voisins
les mesures de lutte contre l'épidémie
ont été prises par simple décret en
France Philippe balle a rappelé c'est la
11e fois que le gouvernement revient
devant dès l'autorisation par l'aimant
permettez-moi de penser dans ces
conditions que les accusations
offusquées d'atteintes aux libertés me
paraissent largement surjoué nous ne les
partagerons donc pas
merci chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à Madame Catherine difolco pour le
groupe les républicains pour 7 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous
concluons donc nos travaux cette semaine
par l'examen d'un texte important sur un
sujet qui nous est désormais très
familier la gestion de la crise
sanitaire le projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions de vigilance
sanitaires et d'ailleurs le 11e texte
consacré à cette question le Parlement
ayant été amené comme il se doit à se
prononcer régulièrement sur le maintien
le renforcement ou l'assouplissement des
différents dispositifs de lutte contre
ce virus à chaque fois le Sénat l'a fait
dans une démarche de responsabilité à
l'égard de nos concitoyens mais il l'a
également fait en mesurant l'ampleur des
perturbations que cela engendre dans la
vie de nombre d'entre eux et en
particulier des restrictions à certaines
libertés que cela entraîne pour ces
raisons notre Assemblée a toujours été
une force de proposition
c'était forcé quand c'était possible
d'arriver à un compromis plus
respectueux des droits et libertés des
Français aujourd'hui le gouvernement
revient donc vers nous avec un nouveau
projet de loi son objectif est
essentiellement de prolonger
l'application de la plupart des
dispositifs actuels le cadre de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire le système
d'information certaines mesures
administratives et économiques
d'accompagnement mais aussi et surtout
le Pass sanitaire ce dernier fait débat
tant parmi nos concitoyens qu'au sein de
la représentation nationale sa mise en
place qui s'apparente à une obligation
vaccinale qui ne veut pas dire son nom
aura sans doute permis d'éviter un
confinement supplémentaire les faciliter
la reprise d'un certain nombre
d'activités et d'accélérer la
vaccination qui atteint à présent un
niveau élevé en métropole ce dont nous
pouvons nous féliciter toutefois n'est
pas sanitaire est également un outil
dont l'emploi s'accompagne
nécessairement de la limitation de
certaines libertés individuelles il ne
peut dès lors intervenir que de manière
proportionnée et adéquate à un moment où
le taux de vaccination en France a
atteint un niveau élevé 86% de la
population de plus de 12 ans et où
l'épidémie n'a plus l'intensité qu'elle
pouvait avoir au début de l'été il est
légitime de songer à la sortie du Pass
sanitaire
certains parmi nous ont argué en faveur
d'une fin plus ou moins immédiate de son
application ne pas souhaiter demeurer
plus longtemps que nécessaire sous
l'empire de ces dispositifs est
compréhensibles mais d'un autre côté la
situation épidémique demeure fluide et
susceptible de connaître des évolutions
soudaines nous l'avons malheureusement
vu le mois dernier en Nouvelle-Calédonie
le maintien d'un cadre robuste de lutte
contre la crise sanitaire et donc
nécessaire le taux de vaccination s'il
est élevé sur le plan national n'est
toutefois pas homogène et reste
comparativement faible par endroits
c'est le cas des Outre-mer tout
particulièrement éprouvé par l'épidémie
durant les derniers mois pas plus tard
le mois dernier nous votion le
prolongement de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire dans un certain nombre des
territoires
ultramarins aujourd'hui encore le
gouvernement nous demande de maintenir
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en Guyane et
Martinique
la démarche de la commission des Lois du
Sénat a été de concilier ces différentes
exigences d'une part ouvrir la voie à
une sortie du Pass sanitaire là où son
application ne serait plus proportionnée
et d'autre part conserver des outils
adéquats pour mettre pour permettre aux
autorités de répondre aux défis
sanitaires à l'initiative des
rapporteurs Philibert et Pascal gruni
dont je salue ici le travail
considérable réalisé dans un laps de
temps très court les commissions des
lois ont voté un texte profondément
modifié
plutôt que de reconduire l'actuel cadre
juridique le projet de loi ainsi amendée
rénove et simplifie les multiples
dispositifs existants afin de permettre
une réponse plus lisible et surtout plus
graduée des pouvoirs publics ainsi
l'exécutif bénéficiera de prérogatives
adaptées à la situation sanitaire
actuelle il pourra maintenir un pass
sanitaire dans une version atténuée mais
uniquement dans les départements ou
moins de 75% de la population est
vaccinée et où le virus circule
activement par contraste là où la
situation s'est améliorée le Pass
sanitaire ne s'appliquera plus de cette
manière il sera possible de contrôler la
propagation de la maladie là où c'est
nécessaire tout en assouplissant les
contraintes pesant sur les Français là
où ces dernières ne seraient plus
proportionnées
par ailleurs en cas de dégradation de la
situation le gouvernement pourrait par
décret et pour une durée limitée à un
mois activez des prérogatives renforcées
inspirés pour partie du dispositif
d'état d'urgence sanitaire cependant ce
dispositif renforcé s'il devait
s'appliquer au-delà d'un mois
impliquerait un contrôle parlementaire
par le biais d'un vote
autre problématique soulevée par le
projet de loi c'est la durée
d'application des différentes mesures
proposées l'exécutif souhaitait les
prolonger jusqu'au 31 juillet prochain
pouvons-nous accepter que le Parlement
ne se prononce plus sur ses
problématiques de sécurité sanitaire et
de liberté fondamentale pendant plus de
sept mois pouvons-nous accepter
d'enjamber ainsi les échéances
électorales majeures dont le résultat
est incertain qui sera l'exécutif quelle
sera la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
il ne serait pas responsable de prendre
ce genre de risque alors pour c'est
pourquoi notre commission a décidé de
ramener cette durée à trois mois et demi
en parfaite cohérence une fois encore
avec les votes précédents du Sénat par
ailleurs le moment venu si la situation
de l'épidémie venait à l'imposer rien
dans les textes n'empêcheraient le
gouvernement de revenir devant nous
après ou même avant le 28 février
en outre un point particulier à retenue
notre attention lors de la discussion du
texte par les députés il s'agit de la
question de l'information des directeurs
d'établissements scolaires sur la
situation virologique de leurs élèves
cette dérogation non justifiée au secret
médical nous avait déjà été proposés
dans la précipitation en juillet dernier
et nous l'avions repoussé pour les mêmes
raisons nous estimons pas judicieux de
mettre en oeuvre une pareille mesure
reconduire le dispositif actuel
d'information plus globale des
responsables d'établissements scolaires
nous paraît donc préférable enfin le
texte de la commission comprend
également un certain nombre d'autres
améliorations appréciables adoptées afin
de veiller à la stricte nécessité de
diverses prorogations mais également de
limiter le recours aux ordonnances ainsi
nos rapporteur ont préféré retirer du
projet de loi plusieurs habilitations à
légiférer par ordonnance et leur
substituer occasionnellement des
dispositions inscrites en clair dans la
loi là aussi le Sénat est en cohérence
avec ses positions historiques sur les
ordonnances de l'article 38 nous aurons
l'occasion d'en discuter plus longuement
la semaine prochaine lors d'examen de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Kester jean-Pierre Sueur au-delà des
mesures qui seront une fine et votées et
parce que nous devrons vivre encore de
longs mois avec ce virus il convient de
ne pas oublier que nous disposons
d'outils simples et efficaces pour nous
protéger protéger notre entourage comme
les gestes barrières ou le télétravail
par exemple pour conclure je salue une
fois encore l'approche pragmatique de
nos rapporteurs partie d'un texte
attentatoire aux libertés individuelles
et au pouvoir législatif et de contrôle
du Parlement ils ont adopté une démarche
de clarté de proportionnalité et
d'équilibre pour la réécriture de ce
projet de loi ainsi soumis à notre vote
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à Monsieur Guy benaroche pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le ministre absent
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
voilà ce que j'avais prévu de dire au
ministre de la Santé s'il avait pris le
temps de venir l'heure n'est pas venu de
nous priver de l'outil qui nous protège
c'est sa déclaration c'est la vôtre
monsieur le ministre et elle mettrig
elle intervient au lendemain du ventre à
l'Assemblée nationale de cette loi et
elle intervient aussi avant que le Sénat
nous-même nous soyons saisis d'une
prolongation éventuelle de ce passe je
l'ai déjà dit je le répète vous traitez
notre chambre non comme un lieu des
choses de discussion de recherche
d'amélioration du texte mais comme une
étape obligatoire dont vous vous
passeriez bien vous entendez bien cette
loi faire passer une énième prolongation
de l'état d'urgence de vos pouvoirs pour
les 8 prochains mois pour aujourd'hui la
consultation légitime du Parlement en
cas de reprise épidémique à une période
peut-être trop proche pour le président
des échéances électorales
dès le début de la crise il y a quelques
mois ici même notre groupe avait alerté
sur le risque d'une généralisation trop
importante de ce Pass sanitaire à la
fois dans le temps dans son périmètre
dans les activités au lieu qu'il
toucherait ou même les maladies ou
causes qui entraînerait sa mise en œuvre
ces crêtes étaient justifiées nous le
voyons aujourd'hui se passe des signes
un projet de société un modèle social
que nous craignons et que nous dénonçons
sous prétexte doc que le Pass sanitaire
protège et protégera vous nous demandez
cette boîte à outils dans l'efficacité
en tant que telle c'est-à-dire le simple
pouvoir de limiter l'accès des personnes
non vaccinées ou non testées à certains
lieux de vie et peut étudier et encore
moins quantifier sur le moyen terme ces
derniers mois il nous est apparu que son
efficacité était surtout lié à
l'incitation à la vaccination qu'il a
suscité et notre groupe reconnaît la
force de l'outil vaccinal dans la lutte
contre la pandémie ce que nous savons
d'ores et déjà c'est que les personnes
les plus fragiles le public prioritaire
n'est toujours pas pas totalement
vacciné que les plus précaires les plus
éloignés de l'épicentre de notre vie
sociale ne le sont pas suffisamment que
85% des plus de 80 ans ont un schéma
vaccinal complet et que le Pass
sanitaire nous rassurement pas un effet
protecteur sur ses populations parlant
des doses maintenant la moitié des
personnes complètement vaccinées ont
reçu les deux doses avant le premier
juillet 2021 le site gouvernemental
lui-même assure que le recul de la
protection actuelle mais en évidence une
protection pendant au moins 6 mois
comment pouvez-vous donc présenter un
texte permettant des mesures
extraordinaires jusqu'au juillet 2022
sans même discuter de cette baisse
d'immunité annoncée de la population
générale vaccinée ce projet de loi
serait-il une sorte de cache-né
d'annonce à venir sur une campagne de
généralisation de la troisième dose
autant parler dès maintenant me
semble-t-il répondre aux questions des
parlementaires qui vous ont été posées
depuis le début de la crise l'état
d'urgence a été à plus de dire reprise
ce projet de loi franchit une nouvelle
étape il crée un état d'urgence de
précaution sur un risque non quantifié
bien sûr des mesures sur une nécessaire
pour faire face à une reprise épidémique
mais pourquoi alors ne rien acheter sur
celle qui ont fait leurs preuves comme
le télétravail ne rien acté sur le
besoin d'une mise en œuvre bien plus
efficace de la vaccination notamment des
plus âgées des plus marginaux ne rien
affirmer non plus sur les gestes
barrières dont nous connaissons pourtant
parfaitement l'efficacité
quel effet pervers du passe l'illusion
de la protection par pass sanitaire
malgré une immunité déclinante
s'accompagnèrent du relâchement des
gestes barrières est un danger bien plus
grand aujourd'hui que vous ne voulez
l'admettre sûrement plus que la
suppression immédiate du passe sanitaire
nous demandez aujourd'hui dans la
situation sanitaire et vaccinale
présente pour ainsi leur moment
d'accepter de nous dessaisir de notre
pouvoir de décision ne nous paraît ni
sérieux ni acceptable quant à la
territorialisation introduite comme une
sorte de compromis par la commission des
lois elle ne nous paraît pas adoptée les
bassins de vie et donc de possibles
contamination n'ont souvent rien à voir
avec des frontières administratives
départementales ou autre au sein même
d'un département entre une métropole
d'os et un village isolé comment
justifier des mêmes mesures avec les
mêmes indicateurs qui sont parfaitement
divergents
et quel indicateurs probants utilisés
adoptés pour cette territorialisation
nous n'avons pas de réponse chers
collègues à ces questions la commission
a jugé utile d'inscrire des critères qui
nous correspondent aucune réalité
épidémiologique intelligible pourcentage
de vacciner ou assez flou circulation
active du virus mesuré par le taux élevé
sans jamais prendre en compte
l'apparition ponctuelle de nouveau
variants l'ancienneté de la vaccination
le taux de reproductibilité effective du
virus nous sénateurs du groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
appelant à des mesures fortes dès
maintenant pour aller vers les
populations non vaccinées à des annonces
claires sur la troisième dose et sans
lien avec une possible désactivation du
Pass sanitaire actuel à des rappels
forts de l'importance des mesures
barrières
tout cela n'a pas besoin ni de
prolongation de l'état d'urgence ni de
maintien du Pass sanitaire c'est
pourquoi nous voterons contre ce texte
contre les pouvoirs concentrés dans les
mains d'un exécutif y compris après les
élections du printemps 2022 contre passa
sanitaire qui présente à ce stage d'une
protection individuelle moindre et quand
une terreau
territorialisation excusez moi qui
intervient son réel critère sanitaire et
introduit de véritable inégalités merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à la
présidente
RCE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous voici
donc aujourd'hui à débattre du 11e
projet de loi visant à instaurer des
mesures sanitaires drastiques dans notre
pays en réponse à la crise sanitaire
liée à l'épidémie de comédie 19 alors si
dans les termes il est plus question
d'état d'urgence mais de vigilance
sanitaires il s'agit pourtant bel et
bien en dehors de la sémantique moins
anxiogène des mêmes dispositifs
d'urgence que ce renouveller
régulièrement ces 18 derniers mois et
accordons au Premier ministre au mini
chargé de la santé et surhabilitation
aux représentants de l'état des pouvoirs
de police administrative exorbitants du
droit commun alors cette diverses ces
divers pardon régime juridique soit
d'état d'urgence soit des tas d'urgence
en débutant ont permis des limitations
des libertés individuelles et
collectives sans précédent liberté de
mouvement liberté de manifester et même
le droit à un procès équitable à un
moment donné aujourd'hui le gouvernement
nous propose principalement de proroger
l'application du régime de gestion de la
crise la terre et du Pass sanitaire
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 et de reporter
la date de caducité du régime de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire au 31 juillet 2022
en parallèle monsieur bas nous propose
un premier nouveau régime entre le 16
novembre et le 28 février qui remplace
le régime de sortie de l'état d'urgence
tout en s'inspirant largement avec des
prérogatives cela dit plus restreintes
ce qui permettrait tout de même d'avoir
recours au passes sanitaire dans les
départements où le taux de vaccination
est inférieur à 75% dans lesquels une
circulation active du virus est constaté
mesurée par un taux d'incidence élevé
vous avez été compris surtout là c'est
quoi nos dionysienne que je suis vous a
bien compris monsieur monsieur bas ce
dispositif est doublé d'un régime plus
dur qui propose un second niveau de
prérogative plus attentatoire aux
libertés que le gouvernement pourrait
activer territorialement pour faire face
à une dégradation forte de la situation
sanitaire alors selon nous si le texte
de la commission est bien plus mesuré
que celui du gouvernement pour preuve
par exemple la suppression des
dispositions visant à créer un
traitement spécifique pour les
établissements scolaires il est
nettement plus respectueux de la
représentation nationale en lui
permettant un contrôle de l'action de
l'exécutif digne de ce nom il n'en
demeure pas moins quand prolongeant la
possibilité d'avoir recours à de tels
régimes le gouvernement comme la
majorité sénatoriale continue à
privilégier une approche sécuritaire de
la gestion de crise et font le choix
d'une politique disciplinaire désormais
banalisée au nom de la prévention
sanitaire
alors que l'épidémie reste
active monsieur capocanellas mais que la
situation c'est nettement améliorée
monsieur kapokanellas notamment grâce à
la vaccination massive nous ne pouvons
continuer à gérer la situation sanitaire
en continuant à concentrer les plats
pouvoirs que lui confère s'est état
d'urgence sanitaire le Conseil
Scientifique indiqué le 5 octobre je
cite contrairement aux précédentes
poussées épidémiques la proportion de
Français vaccinés est aujourd'hui très
élevée et il alert toujours le risque
d'une banalisation du Pass sanitaire et
des mesures de contrôle associé la vie
du 6 octobre c'est-à-dire donc du
lendemain de la vie mentionné du même
conseil et beaucoup plus circonstancié
ce qui ne peut manquer de nous
interroger voire de nous inquiéter en
outre la propos la pro la prolongation
de toutes ces mesures et pour nous
inutiles car si la situation venait à se
dégrader même subitement le gouvernement
pourrait convoquer le Parlement qui
malgré la suspension prévue à partir à
partir du 28 février est amené à siéger
en session ordinaire jusqu'au 30 juin
prochain
sur la reconduction du Pass sanitaire
qui est inquiétant c'est l'accoutumance
de notre pays à ce type d'outils
sera-t-il recyclé à l'avenir pour nous
prévenir d'autres types d'épidémie par
exemple ou peut-être décliné pour les
jeunes enfants dont les parents sont
soumis à plusieurs obligations de
vaccination quel format prendra à
l'avenir ce genre de pas sanitaire on
peut aujourd'hui le présenter sous
format papier peut-être qu'il s'agira
demain de nous photographier grâce à
cette prometteuse technologie de la
reconnaissance faciale on connaît
l'effet cliquet de ce genre de
dispositif à travers notre législation
récente et il est toujours difficile
vous le savez bien de revenir sur nos
libertés perdus nous avons aujourd'hui
toutes les raisons de nous inquiéter
pour l'avenir toutes ces raisons parmi
tant d'autres nous invitent aujourd'hui
à mettre fin à cet outil drastique qui
n'aurait jamais dû être légalisé dans
notre pays d'autres pays voisins
européens sont bien parvenus à un taux
de vaccination satisfaisant comparable
aux nôtre sans savoir eu recours à ce
genre de dispositif vous compris nous
voterons contre ce texte présenté par
notre commission qui est certes une
copie améliorée du texte absolument
inacceptable du gouvernement et nous
vous expliquerons point par point nos
raisons dans le débat merci chers
collègues monsieur le ministre vous
souhaitez monsieur le président
du fond du texte mais un certain nombre
de collègues de groupe socialiste tout à
l'heure sont étonnés de l'absence du
ministre monsieur Olivier Véran j'ai
sans doute manqué à une de mes
obligations auprès des commissaires aux
lois de les avertir que hier il me
l'avait indiqué qu'il ne pourrait pas
être là devant se rendre dans l'Isère
pour des raisons personnelles et
familiales dont j'ai compris qu'elles
étaient très importantes voilà mais je
ne pouvais pas ne pas le dire au Sénat
contenu de l'interrogation qui était
posée tout à l'heure merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
merci monsieur le Président
j'ai le rapporteur monsieur le monsieur
le Président de la Commission mesdames
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs merci
monsieur le Président pour vos pour vos
quelques mots et Monsieur benaroche
chaque membre du gouvernement ici
présent à ce bon représente le
gouvernement dans son ensemble et comme
nous faisons une équipe particulièrement
soudée au sein du ministère des
Solidarités de la Santé je vais me
permettre rapidement de répondre et
polyvalente évidemment complémentaire
efficace je vais me permettre de
répondre à quelques éléments de vos
interventions dans cette discussion dans
cette discussion générale monsieur bam
monsieur le rapporteur
pour commencer par vous merci tout
d'abord d'avoir rappelé le succès de la
campagne de vaccination organisée par le
gouvernement avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes notamment les les élus locaux
et qui a permis à la France d'atteindre
l'un des meilleurs taux de couverture
vaccinale d'Europe l'anticipation la
réactivité dans les commandes dans la
distribution des doses la finesse du
mariage territorial par des sites de
vaccination le soutien financier
matériel humain apporté par l'État la
mobilisation des collectivités locales
je le je le redis et des acteurs
associatifs la participation de
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
notamment des agences régionales de
santé dont je salue le travail
aujourd'hui particulièrement apparaît
après quelques déclarations que j'ai pu
lire ce matin qui m'ont particulièrement
étonné tout cela a permis d'atteindre
collectivement cet objectif madame
Goulet la situation sanitaire n'est pas
si favorable
actuellement avec une légère reprise ça
a été soulevée par un certain nombre
d'entre vous avec une hausse du nombre
de cas le opportunité de faire évoluer
le Pass du niveau réglementaire sera
examiné dans les prochaines semaines le
Gouvernement partage les réserves que
vous avez pu exprimer sur une
territorialisation du passe qui ont été
exprimés aussi par Monsieur benaroche à
l'instant à la fois sur le plan
sanitaire mais aussi pour des questions
de lisibilité des règles applicables par
nos concitoyens et on sait que la
lisibilité des règles et quelque chose
d'important dans l'adhésion qu'ils
peuvent avoir aux dispositions que nous
que nous adoptons merci également madame
boulet d'avoir rappelé l'importance du
respect des gestes barrières dans les
prochains mois et je crois d'ailleurs
que à cet égard le gouvernement va
lancer une grande campagne pour rappeler
effectivement à nos concitoyens
l'importance de ces de ces règles madame
de La Gontrie sur le Pass sanitaire
comme l'indiqué le ministre en
commission sauf erreur
il participe à la réduction de la
circulation du virus conjointement avec
les autres mesures du de freinage je
parle du Pass SAN bien évidemment le
masque gel la distanciation c'est la
question de l'intégration la dose de
rappel au passes sanitaire qui a un
point que vous avez soulevé le
gouvernement a saisi les autorités
scientifiques afin d'identifier si au vu
des risques sanitaires bien évidemment
toujours une telle évolution est
opportune l'incapacité je vous cite du
ministre à répondre sur ce sujet à ce
stade correspond en réalité au souci de
bénéficier d'un éclairage scientifique
suffisant et de prendre le temps de la
réflexion je suis sûr que vous me
rejoindrez que vous nous rejoindrez que
vous rejoindrez le ministre sur ce point
madame la sénatrice madame carraire le
périmètre actuel du passé sanitaire a
été défini en accord entre les deux
assemblées dans la loi du 5 août que
vous avez débattu l'outil est désormais
bien accepté me semble-t-il par nos
concitoyens il permet de maintenir
l'ensemble des activités de loisirs il
rassure aussi nos compatriotes son
périmètre sera adapté à l'évolution de
la situation sanitaire à la circulation
du virus l'évolution de la vaccination à
la mobilisation
du système hospitalier la bifolco enfin
l'accès des directeurs d'établissements
scolaires aux données
virologique et vaccinal est nécessaire
pour fiabiliser et améliorer la campagne
de dépistage et de vaccination auprès
des jeunes nous allons avoir je le pense
de nombreux débats à ce sujet au cours
de cette séance c'est la condition pour
pour faire progresser et pour raffiner
le protocole sanitaire en place dans les
écoles depuis quelques semaines et qui
vise à limiter vous le savez les
fermetures de classe en cas de cas
positif et en permettant aux élèves
testés négatifs de revenir dès le
lendemain en classe et que nos élèves
puissent continuer à bénéficier de
l'éducation et puis de la relation
qu'ils ont avec leurs camarades aussi on
a vu les effets sur la santé mentale des
enfants qui avaient pu avoir la
fermeture des classes quand nous avions
été obligé de le faire l'année dernière
enfin monsieur benaroche nous avons
manifestement des points de divergence
notamment sur ma présence à ce banc
semble-t-il je vous remercie pour vos
remarques fort peu fort peu amène mais
le gouvernement on partage les réserves
que vous avez exprimées sur la
perspective d'une territorialisation du
Pass sanitaire par rapport à des
frontières administratives vous l'avez
dit et selon des critères sanitaires
rigides fixés dans la loi nous en
reparlerons dans quelques instants enfin
monsieur le sénateur malurey je pense
pouvoir vous rejoindre sur un certain
nombre des propos que vous avez
et
Madame assis je vous aurons l'occasion
au cours du débat je d'avoir d'avoir des
échanges je n'en doute pas et pas
patiente je sais voilà monsieur le
Président pour ces quelques éléments de
réponse monsieur le ministre la
discussion générale est close nous
passons à la discussion du texte de la
commission et à l'article premier a j'ai
deux prises de parole de Monsieur Yann
chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre avec ce projet de loi portant
divers dispositions dites de vigilance
sanitaires le gouvernement nous demande
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises une
onzième fois de prolonger un régime
d'exception alors que rien ne justifie
de lui offrir ce pouvoir
disproportionner aujourd'hui plus de 80%
des plus de 12 ans sont vaccinés les
masques et les tests de dépistage sont
disponibles en grande quantité et les
taux d'incidence et de positivité au
test est très bas et pourtant le
gouvernement nous demande au cas où de
lui donner les moyens d'imposer un
reconfinement ou un couvre-feu quand bon
lui semble sans avoir à nous consulter
shooter depuis des mois à la prise de
décision non concertée et non contrôlée
voilà que le gouvernement vient nous en
demander une nouvelle dose mes
compatriotes établis hors de France qui
vivent dans des pays où le Parlement
exerce un contrôle très large sur
l'action du gouvernement me disent
souvent à quel point ils sont choqués de
voir le gouvernement piétiner les droits
du Parlement chez nous et donc mépriser
les Françaises et les Français que nous
représentons
ce projet de loi qui nous demande de
prolonger une nouvelle fois des
dispositions liberticides et vos
amendements à cet article premier par
lesquels vous vous entêtez à vouloir
revenir à la date du 2 31 juillet sont
une nouvelle démonstration de votre
mépris du Parlement et du peuple
français c'est pourquoi je vous demande
de faire preuve de respect vis-à-vis de
nos compatriotes en revenant sur votre
intention de passer par-dessus le
Parlement jusqu'au 31 juillet
la parole est à Madame Benbassa
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
titre premier a est injustifiable par
rapport au fait les dernières données
puis de Myologie attestent de taux
d'incidence beaucoup moins élevée qu'au
plus fort de la crise la vaccination
atteint un record 85 % des Français dont
plus de 90% pour l'étrange d'âge les
plus à risque ont été vaccinés de ce
fait il est plus raisonnable comme la
soutenu la commission de restreindre le
Pass sanitaire au seul département ou
moins de 75% de la population est
complètement vaccinée le maintien de ce
dispositif sur l'ensemble du territoire
sans justification sanitaire est
attentatoire aux libertés comme un
refrain vous ne cessez de répéter que
l'obligation du Pass sanitaire pousse à
la vaccination massive et que l'objectif
sera très bien tôt atteint c'est
pourquoi le Sénat a tenu à limiter au 28
février années 2022 l'utilisation par
décret du Premier ministre je crains que
l'exécutif et puis la mauvaise habitude
des interdictions par décret vous
semblez nier les problèmes à venir pour
les élections présidentielles et
législatives y aurait-il besoin d'un
passe pour aller voter à quelques mois
de ces échéances j'en appelle un peu
plus de clairvoyance dans vos décisions
en juillet dernier la Défenseur des
droits appelés de ses vœux
l'organisation d'un débat démocratique
publique je soutiens cette initiative
qui permettrait d'éclairer les zones
d'ombre qui entourent le prolongement de
ce Pass sanitaire je le souhaite des
centaines de mails comme les autres de
famille en souffrance qui sont
réellement impactés dans leur quotidien
se sont en marginalisés ne pas sanitaire
provoque une véritable rupture du lien
social puisque aujourd'hui rien ne peut
se faire sans se passe s'il est
dispositions de cet article sont adoptés
cela signifiera que le gouvernement
souhaite que le Parlement lui offre un
blanc sans pendant encore 8 mois sans
aucune possibilité de révision c'est le
rôle du Parlement qui est remis en cause
merci merci cher collègue deux
amendements identiques le 64
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues c'est reparticle 1er a
de la Commission à des lois crée un
nouveau régime entre le 16 novembre et
le 28 février qui remplace de fait le
régime de sortie de l'état d'urgence
avec des prérogatifs plus restreintes
selon lequel le gouvernement pourrait
réglementer sur les restrictions de
liberté comme sur la possibilité de se
déplacer ou l'ouverture au public de
l'établissements en se vend du public
par exemple ou encore sur le recours au
passes sanitaire dans les départements
où le taux de vaccination est inférieur
à 75% et dans lesquels une circulation
active du virus est constatée mesurée
par un taux d'incidence élevé quel que
soit les efforts qu'on sentit par la
commission des Lois du Sénat pour
prendre en compte les inquiétudes
légitimes de nombre de nos concitoyens
et de nombre d'observateurs d'acteurs de
la vie publique et politique nous
n'approuvons pas cette réécriture du
texte celle-ci apparaissent certes bien
plus mesurée que le dispositif présenté
par le gouvernement mais s'inscrit à nos
yeux dans la même que les précédents
examens par le Sénat des textes du
gouvernement un texte moins attentats
aux libertés publiques au délai de fin
de régime plus rapprochés dans le temps
mais avec des moyens qui demeurent très
similaires visant au même objectifs
aussi globalement nous réitérons notre
opposition à la prorogation de ce régime
juridique d'exception qui renforce
considérablement les pouvoirs de
l'exécutif et bien normaliser parfois
même banaliser des mesures exorbitantes
du droit commun le contrôle et la
limitation stricte dans le temps de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sont
essentielles afin de préserver un
équilibre entre objectif sanitaire et
garanti de l'état de droite elle est le
sens de notre proposition de suppression
chez chers collègues l'amendement 83
monsieur ravier
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
reprendre à mon compte la formule de la
plus éminente de nos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale car elle résume
assez bien la situation soit le vaccin
est efficace et le passe ne se justifie
plus soit le vaccin n'empêche pas la
prorogation la propagation du virus et
le passe ne se justifie plus
monsieur le ministre vous avez négligé
le renouvellement du stock de masse vous
avez négligé la fermeture des frontières
vous avez négligé l'examen des eaux
usées vous avez négligé la recherche
d'un traitement vous avez négligé la
fermeture par centaines de lit
d'hôpitaux vous avez négligé le sort des
personnels soignants et cette négligence
généralisée se traduit aujourd'hui en
dizaine de milliers de morts et
maintenant nous sommes au prix nous
sommes pris au piège dans un tunnel sans
fin de contrainte de contrôle de
restriction et de culpabilisation la
grande mutation autoritaire engagée dans
cette crise nous fait craindre le pire
pour nos libertés à court à moyen et à
long terme il nous faut retrouver nos
plein droit et nos libertés maintenant
nous avons trop reculé dans ce texte la
droite sénatoriale propose de ne
proroger le Pass sanitaire que jusqu'au
28 février grand seigneur mais à force
de compromis permanence son refus
d'opposition vire à la compromission à
un soutien qui ne dit pas son nom elle
refuse le avant de la voir commencer
l'exécutif trinque à votre santé à la
santé de l'opposition docile cet
amendement propose d'en finir avec le
Pass sanitaire au 15 novembre comme
prévu initialement plus que 15 jours à
tenir dans cette folie liberticide à la
condition unique d'avoir le courage de
voter cet amendement merci cher collègue
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président la vie sans
surprise et défavorable nous avons
préféré réécrire cet article plutôt que
de le supprimer mais nous avons mis des
conditions drastiques pour que le Pass
sanitaire ne puisse plus être utilisé
que dans des conditions qui le mettent
en quelque sorte en voie d'extinction
merci monsieur le ministre
oui ça sera la vie défavorable du
gouvernement
les deux amendements identiques 64 83 de
suppression avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
l'amendement 80 du gouvernement monsieur
ministre merci monsieur le Président
voilà je me suis permis de me limiter un
avis défavorable sans véritablement
développer sur le les précédents
amendement qui est des amendements de
suppression de la rédaction du de la
commission la direction sur laquelle cet
amendement numéro 80 du gouvernement
vous propose de revenir afin de rétablir
les dispositions relatives à cette
prolongation elle adaptation du régime
de sortie dans leur rédaction qui vous
avez été transmise au Sénat en effet la
circulation du virus augmente dans toute
l'Europe ça a été souligné par un
certain nombre d'entre vous le risque de
rebond épidémique va demeurer élever
pour plusieurs mois encore en raison de
l'entrée toute prochaine dans la période
hivernale dont vous savez nous savons
qu'elle est propice à une accélération
de la circulation du virus
une grande vigilance s'impose en outre
face aux risques d'apparition d'un
nouveau variant que nous ne pouvons
prévoir aujourd'hui au caractéristiques
qui pourraient être différentes de
celles que nous connaissons déjà et dans
ce contexte qui demeure donc un contexte
incertain il est indispensable de
prolonger jusqu'à l'été les outils de
gestion de l'épidémie de façon à pouvoir
réagir à toute nouvelle dégradation de
la situation sanitaire aucun d'entre
nous ici ne peut prévoir comment les
semaines prochaines vont évoluer le
régime de sortie défini par la loi du 31
mai 2021 et le Pass sanitaire ont en
effet démontré leur efficacité pour
contenir la circulation du virus pour
limiter les conséquences de cette
circulation sur la population et sur le
système de santé
tout en permettant à la vie économique
et à la vie sociale de notre pays de nos
concitoyens de se poursuivre alors si je
suis favorable à un encadrement plus
strict du Pass sanitaire j'estime comme
les députés que cette encadrement doit
reposer sur la prise en compte de
plusieurs critères non pas d'un seul
dont l'incident mais aussi le taux de
positivité des tests la couverture
vaccinale l'attention hospitalière bref
l'ensemble de ces indicateurs qui nous
guident depuis le début de cette
épidémie et de la gestion que nous en
faisons je permet d'ajouter enfin même
si ça a été dit par un certain nombre
d'entre vous que le Conseil Scientifique
et le Conseil d'État ont chacun dans
leur rôle valider tant le principe du
maintien des outils actuels que la date
du 31 juillet 2022 tels que défendu par
le gouvernement voilà monsieur le
Président le sens de cet amendement
[Musique]
c'est le président la commission ne peut
qu'être défavorable à cet amendement
puisque il rétablit non pas le texte du
Gouvernement mais le texte est adopté
par l'Assemblée nationale et nous avons
précisément voulu le modifier dans le
sens qu'il y a déjà été indiqué merci
de votre
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je crois qu'il ne doit pas y
avoir de malentendu entre nous monsieur
le ministre
personne en tout cas dans notre groupe
mais je crois dans la plupart de nos
collègues ne-y la possibilité d'une
évolution
épidémiologique d'un développement d'un
nouveau variant et donc de mesures qui
devront le jour venu de voir être prise
la véritable question et avec le
rétablissement de la rédaction initiale
que vous nous proposez et est-ce que
l'on autorise jusqu'au mois de juillet
prochain et ainsi enjambant l'élection
présidentielle et législatives ces
mesures qui de fait sont des mesures de
restriction d'un certain nombre de
liberté qui peuvent être y compris
vécues comme attentatoire à la liberté
donc voilà je préfère le préciser parce
que le pas que nous avons et bien sûr le
calendrier les mesures prises le
contrôle et l'association du Parlement
et dans la capacité à décider de
celle-ci parce que j'ai entendu
également votre collègue avant la
coupure mais
vous pouvez venir toutes les semaines
nous parler
travailler et entendre ce qu'on va dire
les parlementaires ce n'est pas la même
chose que de venir chaque semaine
répéter ce que l'on a à dire donc ce
n'est pas la combien de fois vous allez
revenir c'est effectivement s'assurer
avoir les moyens de la garantie
démocratique parce que de toutes les
façons un des enjeux aussi quand nous
sommes dans une crise et quelle qu'elle
soit c'est de rétablir la confiance
entre les Français leurs institutions et
les mesures qu'elles mettent en oeuvre
merci chers collègues
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
nous contestons pas malheureusement
l'évolution de la situation dans un
certain nombre de pays qui ne doit nous
inciter à la vigilance et à considérer
que les choses ne sont malheureusement
loin d'être terminée et peuvent rebondir
toutefois monsieur le ministre il est
absolument inacceptable d'imaginer que
nous vous laissions la possibilité sans
débat parlementaire
de décider les choses sur plus de 6 mois
sachant qu'en plus ce sera pas
nécessairement vous
bon
nous avons nous voyons aussi nous sommes
profondément convaincus que si la lutte
contre cette épidémie ne peut pas se
faire en vous laissant les clés ou en
laissant les clés au gouvernement des
choses pendant 6 mois nous sommes
convaincus que des débats parlementaires
de manière systématique et renouvelée à
chaque fois que la situation évolue sont
nécessaires c'est bien ce qui est fait
depuis un an et demi maintenant pourquoi
voulez-vous parce qu'il y a des
échéances électorales vous évitez ces
débats et et et d'affronter au Parlement
la réalité de la situation il n'est pas
du tout acceptable de laisser les choses
sans débat parlementaire pendant 6 mois
le Parlement peut travailler en février
en mars si nécessaire s'il y a des
évolutions et nous sommes convaincus que
c'est parce que le gouvernement les
représentant du peuple peuvent débattre
de ces sujets que nous pourrons le mieux
possible adapter les mesures à la
situation il n'est donc pas normal de
vous donner
les mains libres sans contrôle pendant
plus de six mois sur ces sujets qui sont
effectivement parfois attentats aux
libertés
oui merci monsieur le Président quelques
quelques mots rapides je voudrais
rappeler que nous ne sommes pas dans une
crise simple nous sommes dans une
pandémie une pandémie c'est-à-dire
qu'elle touche le monde entier et
qu'elle n'est pas tout à fait gérable
comme on le voudrait je voudrais
rappeler comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure que les chiffres ne sont pas
merveilleux pour l'instant et qu'ils
sont même inquiétants si on regarde
d'autres pays que il a été souvent
reproché et ces derniers mois enfin il y
a quelques mois un manque de pédagogie
du gouvernement un manque de pédagogie
dans les explications et qu'on le
travail qui a été fait sur le pas
sanitaire avec nous tous d'ailleurs a
donné d'excellents résultats avec cette
pédagogie fonctionne pour autant elle ne
fonctionne pas suffisamment puisqu'il
reste encore un certain nombre de
personnes non vaccinées donc en danger
et à ça je voudrais rajouter que le
personnel soignant je l'ai dit aussi et
excessivement fatigué qu'il a besoin de
stabilité et qu'il a besoin de signes de
notre part et ces signes c'est la
stabilité dans les décisions qui ont été
prises nous avons aujourd'hui deux
outils extraordinaire le vaccin
visiblement des gens ne sont pas
d'accord avec moi sur le vaccin ce qui
m'ennuie et nous avons et nous et nous
avons un autre outil et nous avons un
autre outil qui est le Pass sanitaire
cet outil fonctionne bien c'est
important que dans le temps surtout dans
un moment avec l'hiver qui arrive ou la
pandémie peut repartir d'autant plus
fort que nous gardons ces outils à un
certain temps et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut soutenir la maman du gouvernement
je vous remercie c'est chers
si monsieur le Président la discussion
pourtant sur la réécriture totale d'un
article évidemment il est impossible il
est exhaustif en 2 minutes je voudrais
donc juste donner quelques éléments qui
expliquent pourquoi j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que le texte de la commission
n'est pas satisfaisant le premier point
c'est la territorialisation
le premier prince et la
territorialisation d'abord établir deux
critères et deux critères seulement pour
supprimer le Pass sanitaire le taux de
vaccination et taux d'incidence c'est
d'une part une rigidité qui n'est pas
souhaitable et d'autre part c'est une
insuffisance de critères qui en matière
de santé publique ne se justifient pas
il faut laisser une souplesse dans dans
la et c'est d'ailleurs ce sur quoi le
conseil scientifique travaille en
permanence parce que c'est plus il y a
beaucoup plus que ça donc les deux
critères me paraissent totalement
insuffisants pour le définir
deuxièmement la fixation d'un seuil
rigide par département et ignore la
réalité
ignorent les déplacements il y a pas de
frontières entre les déplacements en
France et notamment au moment des
périodes touristiques vous allez vous
apercevoir c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
que c'était une idée à gaz que personne
ne va plus rien y comprendre et que ce
serait extrêmement difficile à appliquer
qu'il y aura bien entendu beaucoup de
protestations beaucoup
d'incompréhensions deuxième réflexion on
a on réduit le périmètre du passé
sanitaire en excluant certaines
activités dans la nouvelle rédaction de
la Commission
ça peut paraître normal aujourd'hui
parce que les les l'épidémie est en
régression encore que mais si je
précisément en cas de recrudescence
qu'il faut prévoir les mesures et je et
devant laquelle nous manquerions de
certaines de ces mesures si nous les
avions exclu à l'avant donc je ne suis
pas partisan de réduire dès aujourd'hui
ces mesures troisièmement je comprends
pas la nécessité de bâtir un nouveau
régime de gestion de la crise sanitaire
alors que le régime actuel a fait la
preuve de son efficacité et que très
franchement entre nous les français ou
les loyers comme moi sont loin de s'en
plaindre je dirais même que ça les
rassure et enfin pour terminer
l'échéance du 31 juillet 2022 a fait
l'objet de toutes les interventions en
direction générale je n'ai pas le temps
d'y revenir et je n'y reviens pas on
sait tous expliqué là-dessus merci chers
collègues
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre
je pense que enfin je pensais jusqu'à il
y a quelques instants que le débat qui
s'engageait avait une sorte de
légitimité et que nous étions tous en
train de chercher à ce stade de
l'épidémie qui a faibli mais qui n'est
pas complètement derrière nous j'en
conviens comment on prenait les
meilleurs dispositions pour pouvoir en
sortir et emmener le maximum de nos
concitoyens dans une démarche d'en
sortir j'ai d'abord été un petit peu
refroidie par les premiers mots de votre
de votre collègue monsieur le ministre
qui nous a dit d'entrée de jeu nous
sommes déterminés sur la date du 31
juillet
bon ça au germal d'un débat constructif
il me semble
et ça augure mal de la perception qu'on
a tous c'est à dire que il y a quelque
chose derrière tout ça
ce qui doit la seule boussole qui doit
nous conduire qui doit nous guider les
uns et les autres c'est la gestion
sanitaire de cette crise et c'est les
mesures sanitaires à prendre beaucoup
ont expliqué mieux que je ne vais le
faire que c'est parti avaient une forme
de politisation de ce débat qui a eu
quelques personnes réfractaires à la
vaccination donc ne poursuivons pas dans
ce sens et donc il me semble qu'il faut
que ce débat ait lieu oui il y a un
problème démocratique derrière cette
volonté d'enjamber des échéances
majeures dans notre pays quant à
l'argument de dire l'hôpital est en
tension mais voilà on se débats
puisqu'il a été évoqué que ça fait 11
fois que nous discutions discutons de
ces questions voilà onze débats au moins
que nous ne cessons de mettre la
question de l'hôpital sur la table le
président du conseil scientifique vient
encore de dire hier qu'il y avait 20%
des lits d'hôpitaux qui étaient
aujourd'hui fermées faute de soign
et ben voilà une question à laquelle il
faudrait répondre et ça n'est pas par
des mesures de restriction des libertés
qu'on répondra à cette question majeure
la parole à Monsieur gay
ah oui c'est pour toi
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues non mais moi ça me
fait pas rire
d'abord il y a une question c'est que et
nous l'avons plaidé depuis le débat
depuis le départ pardonnez-moi nous
pensons pas que le Parlement est un
obstacle à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et depuis le premier le
premier texte nous avons plaidé pour une
association avec le gouvernement
et c'est pas le choix que vous avez fait
et je vais pas rentrer dans des
polémiques parce que la question n'est
pas là mais enfin si tout avait été
réussi par le gouvernement et par la
verticalité ça serait et nous nous avons
dit associé le Parlement c'est pas un
empêcheur c'est un des moyens pour être
le plus efficace possible et pour le
coup c'est pour ça qu'on repense et un
certain nombre que si nous nous sommes
opposés à la cette prolongation l'état
d'urgence mais on peut pas donner un
quitus pour 7 ou 8 mois supplémentaires
et qu'il sera bien bien temps si la
situation évolue de se revoir avant
deuxième chose et je ne laisserai pas
passer ça parce que Monsieur lévrier
quand vous trouverez vers nous et vous
dites il y a un débat et laissez
supposer même pas le dire que nous
serions anti vaccin ça c'est pas correct
parce que depuis le début ici nous nous
avons dit non à l'état d'urgence non pas
sanitaire mais oui il y a un il y a la
vaccination et nous avons d'ailleurs
plaidé depuis le départ pour notre part
pour la levée universelle des brevets
sur la question maximale lorsque
d'ailleurs vous vous y êtes toujours
opposé donc la question franchement
c'est pas bien du tout d'avoir dit ça et
de laisser entendre parce que nous
serions contre l'état d'urgence pour la
démocratie le respect du Parlement
contre le patient notaire mais pour la
vaccination que nous serions contre la
vaccination je pense qu'il y a assez
d'endroits où la parole publique est
discréditée pour qu'il comprit si au
Parlement vous vous en faciez le relais
des pires merci chers qui se dit
franchement j'attends que vous excusiez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues je
partage la colère de Fabien gay et je
comprends parfaitement pourquoi monsieur
le ministre vous venez maintenant avec
cette loi vous
l'instrumentaliser dans un débat
politique qui tend à faire croire que le
président serait l'incarnation de la
raison et son opposition l'incarnation
du mal et serait finalement nous nous
serions contre la vaccination je je
tiens à vous dire de façon extrêmement
solennelle que ce dont nous discutons
ici c'est de la préservation de l'État
droit c'est de la préservation de la
Constitution la Constitution n'est pas
abolie par l'épidémie ce que nous
voulons c'est des arguments juridiques
des arguments de droit pas des arguments
médicaux car ce que nous défendons ici
encore une fois c'est la Constitution le
Gouvernement a utilisé pendant toute la
période des crises des pouvoirs
exorbitant des pouvoirs qui sont
supérieurs à celui que lui donne
l'article 36 de la Constitution sur
l'état de siège je vous rappelle que
lait de sa sièges il doit régulièrement
être progrogé par le Parlement ce que
nous règlement c'est de réinstituer le
pouvoir des parlements ce que vous
voulez c'est que nous nous abordions
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle nous
le refuserons de façon solennelle merci
monsieur le Président cher collègue
monsieur Richard
merci monsieur le Président celui-ci
chers collègues gouvernant par cet
amendement souhaite réintroduire le
texte dont il nous a saisi
je voudrais
certes cette bonne guerre mais je
voudrais vraiment dire monsieur le
ministre que ce n'est pas ainsi que vous
allez montrer votre volonté de
collaborer véritablement avec la chambre
haute pour élaborer un texte qui puisse
être autant consensuel que possible
répondre à l'urgence de la situation
les deux commissions commissions des
lois les commissions des affaires
sociales ont travaillé sur votre texte
et
très majoritairement montrer qu'elle
n'en voulait pas dès lors commencer ce
débat en nous disant ben écoutez c'est à
prendre ou à laisser voici mon texte
excusez-moi de le dire comme ça mais
c'est un discours que je ne veux pas
entendre ici
l'heure n'est plus à cela n'est plus à
cette discussion là à l'heure et à se
poser la question de savoir si oui ou
non les sénateurs ici présents sont
d'accord avec la proposition faite par
les deux commissions à savoir revenir du
31 juillet au 28 février pour la fin de
ces dispositions et deuxièmement savoir
si oui ou non elles sont d'accord c'est
les sénateurs sont d'accord pour une
territorialisation du Pass sanitaire
dans les conditions prévues par les deux
commissions moi titre personnel je dis
très clairement je suis en désaccord
flagrant avec votre proposition de
réintroduction de votre texte mais je
serai aussi en désaccord
et je l'ai déjà dit en commission des
lois avec le texte de monsieur le
rapporteur de se le rapporteur et de
Madame la rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales je pense que le
temps maintenant est venu
d'arrêter avec le pas sanitaire qui a au
moins un effet pervers et ça tout le
monde sera la gorge c'est qu'à partir du
moment où on a montré son passe
sanitaire quelque part plus aucune geste
barrière n'est applicable plus rien les
gens se serrent les mains comme avant
c'est tout juste il ne s'embrasse pas et
et plus de masque et ça c'est
franchement intolérable donc il faut
revenir sur ça monsieur le ministre mais
c'est la raison une raison essentielle
pour lesquelles moi je souhaite revenir
à un état normal
merci chers collègues monsieur benaroche
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que j'avais
eu des propos peu à même à votre égard
je ne sais pas lesquels en tout cas moi
je me permets de vous dire quand ce qui
me concerne et en ce qui concerne
certains nombres de mes collègues ici
nous trouvons nous que votre déclaration
à l'instant tout comme le projet de loi
que vous nous avez présenté
démontre un véritable dédain du
gouvernement pour le législateur et
particulièrement pour le Sénat il faut
vous l'entendiez monsieur le ministre ce
ne sont pas des propos peu amen c'est le
reflet du sentiment aujourd'hui de la de
la réalité de ce que nous jugeons à la
fois de la proposition qui tord à nous
éliminer pendant huit mois de toute
possibilité de contrôle ou de décision
et en même temps à vos propos qui nous
disent en quelque sorte c'est à prendre
ou à laisser donc monsieur le ministre
les propos peu amènent
correspondrait peut-être au dédain que
vous avez vis-à-vis de nous
en fait nous avons assisté pendant un
certain temps mais semble-t-il monsieur
le ministre lors de cette crise depuis
le début de cette crise a des reproches
que nous avons fait
à l'exécutif de réflexion trop tardive
de décision solidaires de décision
tardive d'un président qui semblait au
début ne s'écoutait que lui-même pour
choisir un certain ordre de décision
entouré d'un comité de défense nous ne
savions pas exactement à quoi il
correspondait et suite à cette période
là aujourd'hui nous avons vraiment le
sentiment en fait que vous voulez
décider trop tôt et que vous voulez
décider surtout en exerçant de manière
déviante le pouvoir en l'occurrence on
ne pouvant pas en vous demandant
d'accorder de vous accorder à vous et à
un autre prochain futur inconnu
gouvernement dans un deux élections un
blanc sain jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet monsieur le ministre quel que
soit nos positions sanitaire sur la
crise sanitaire quel que soit à nos
positions vis-à-vis des taux de
pourcentage vaccinal ou autre je vous le
dis clairement le Sénat ne vous accorde
pas de blancs sains pour huit mois
madame Assassi
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
outre les aspects démocratiques et de
respect des droits du Parlement qui se
pose mais qui ne se pose pas qu'à l'aune
de du projet de loi qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui quand même dire que ça fait
quelques années que le Parlement est
maltraité par par le les gouvernements
et particulièrement durant ces dernières
années la fin du complet de 5 ans avec
cette multiplication
d'ordonnance mais je pense surtout qu'il
faut savoir faire preuve ici parce que
c'est le Sénat aussi faire preuve
d'honnêteté et de sincérité
cela était dit la situation sanitaire va
mieux et nous nous en satisfaisons parce
qu'il y a eu
la vaccination je voudrais pas rappeler
aussi tout comment les handicaps qu'on a
dû surmonter pour que nos concitoyens et
nos concitoyennes puissent avoir accès à
la vaccination méta et mais infêtait que
la vaccination et nous sommes favorables
à la vaccination je ne cesserai de le
répéter comme nous sommes favorables à
la troisième dose vaccination a
contribué à ce recul de l'épidémie et
nous espérons qu'il en sera ainsi et que
nous en finirons bientôt mais monsieur
lévrier je
rebondis sur ce qu'a dit Fabien gay je
vous demande des excuses
de laisser reponcer que nous aurions été
ne serait-ce que l'instinct d'une nano
seconde opposée à la vaccination c'est
faux donc je vous demande des excuses
tous nos maires et pas simplement les
mères communistes d'autres maires
d'autres formations politiques ou
utiliser tous les outils à leur
disposition pour que nos concitoyens et
nos concitoyens puissent se faire
vacciner mais ça monsieur vous ne pouvez
pas le connaître vous qui êtes si peu en
responsabilité de gestion d'une
collectivité merci chers collègues
madame de la ganterie
la parole merci monsieur le Président
j'écoute chacune des interventions et je
pense à cette expression que vous
connaissez c'est un éléphant au milieu
de la pièce
cette date du 31 juillet tous les
arguments que vous avez donné sont juste
mais arrêtons de nous raconter des
histoires pourquoi est-ce que cette date
est proposée parce que le Président de
la République qui n'est pas encore
candidat pense qu'il le sera avant la
fin février et qui n'a aucune envie de
devoir assumer un débat par le menteur
sur la question de la prolongation ou
non de l'état d'urgence sanitaire voilà
la réponse voilà pourquoi je parle des
d'éléphants au milieu de la pièce et
voilà pourquoi jus préféré que le
ministre dise les choses comme tel
lorsque nous l'avons auditionné donc la
question est celle là le président de la
République sera candidat un jour ne lui
en déplaise il devra assumer ce débat et
tant d'autres encore même au mois de
février merci cher collègue donc je mets
au voile amendement 80 du gouvernement
avec un avis défavorable à commission
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté 23
amendements en discussion commune le 6
monsieur benaroche
président
à tous ces amendements mais bon
cet amendement est un amendement de
repli qui correspond à la position que
nous avons exprimé déjà lors des
passages des différentes projets de loi
lors de cette assemblée en fait devant
cette assemblée
c'est un amendement de repli puisque
notre position est assez simple en fait
nous prétendant que l'utilisation du
Pass sanitaire dans le cas où le Pass
sanitaire serait renouvelé ne devrait
pouvoir se justifier
sanitairement puisque ça passe sanitaire
de manière raisonnable que dans les
endroits où l'implication des gestes
barrières du port du masque n'est pas
possible seulement dans ces endroits là
uniquement dans sa dans ces endroits là
et non pas d'une manière généralisée ou
généralisable son utilisation pourrait
avoir un sens quand la mise en oeuvre de
ces mesures de nature à prévenir les
risques de propagation les gestes
barrières le port du masque les jauges
mis en place le sens de circulation les
mis la supposition de gel hydraulique
alcoolique pardon et autres ne
pourraient pas être mis en place ou ne
pourrez pas avoir lieu ou être mis en
oeuvre correctement donc nous demandons
à modifier donc l'article première a
pour préciser donc les lieux où le Pass
sanitaire pourrait être exigé chers
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des lois
mesdames Madame et Monsieur il est
rapporteur et mes chers collègues cet
amendement tant à permettre l'imposition
d'un Pass sanitaire pour accéder aux
établissements accueillants des
personnes vulnérables dans l'ensemble
des départements les personnes
accueillies dans les établissements de
santé sociaux et médico-sociaux on fait
partie des publics prioritaires pour
l'accès à la vaccination ils sont donc
majoritairement vaccinés cependant leur
état de vulnérabilité extrême nécessite
de prendre un maximum de précaution pour
leur éviter une exposition virus une
contamination même minime peut avoir des
effets redoutables contenus des
multiples facteurs de comorbidité
merci chers collègues quatre amendements
identiques le 7 monsieur benaroche
qui est par cet amendement un peu quel
est notre position en fait sur la
territorialisation du pas sanitaire en
fait pourquoi nous y sommes opposés en
tout cas de
déjà de la façon dont il est prévu dans
dans le projet qui nous est proposé
d'une manière plus générale
effectivement il nous semble que la
définition des critères qui permettrait
de territorialiser se passe sont assez
arbitraires pourquoi 73% de vaccination
d'abord et de la population globale
pourquoi en plus ne parlez que d'un taux
de vaccination alors qu'on sait très
bien aujourd'hui que dans les courbes
dans le parallélisme qui peut exister il
y en a aucun on fait il n'y en a pas en
tout cas il n'est pas il n'y a pas de
parallélisme votre à la fois entre le
taux de vaccination d'un côté et
l'immunité de l'autre pour plusieurs
raisons ne serait-ce que parce que tout
le monde le dit c'est une chose acquise
aujourd'hui maintenant l'immunité baisse
en fonction bien entendu du temps entre
la vaccination et le moment où elle est
mesurée
elle est également très différente enfin
en fonction des personnes vous savez des
personnes âgées des personnes fragiles
ou même des sujets jeunes ce qui veut
dire en fait que actuellement plus de
50% des personnes ayant reçu leurs deux
doses avant le premier juillet le poids
considérer que
le Pass sanitaire acquis grâce à la
vaccination n'a plus réellement ou aura
de moins en moins de sens concernant
l'immunité acquise et nous disons en
fait que ce qui doit compter ce n'est
pas le taux de vaccination mais c'est
bien l'immunité supposée acquise par le
parcours vaccinal
et qu'il est possible qu'un département
est peut-être 90% de vacciner qu'il ait
été tous c'est une démonstration par
l'absurde avant le 1er juillet
sans rappel de la troisième dose
puisqu'on ne sait rien de la troisième
dose et qu'un autre département à côté
n'aurait que 70% de vacciner mais tout
ça après le premier juillet et donc le
département qui aurait 90% de vacciner
ben échappé au Pass sanitaire alors que
l'immunité globale de ce département
aurait nettement baissé alors que le
département qui reçoit du ports vacciner
lui repérer dans le cadre du passe
sanitaire merci merci chers collègues le
27 madame Noël merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues alors que les équipements de
protection individuelle sont aujourd'hui
largement disponibles que nous disposons
d'une des meilleures couvertures
vaccinales d'Europe que la circulation
du virus est globalement contenue on
veut nous accoutumer encore et toujours
à cet état d'urgence permanent qui prend
peu à peu la place de la démocratie
pleine et entière
à ce traçage électronique qui accompagne
désormais tous nos gestes de la vie
quotidienne à géométrie variable avec un
nombre incalculable d'incohérences et
d'aberration un passe pour le TGV mais
pas pour les le métro pour une école de
musique associative mais pas pour une
école de musique communale pour accéder
à une bibliothèque municipale mais pas
pour un meeting politique alors que le
gouvernement nous jurait la main sur le
cœur en mars dernier que se passe ne
concernerait que les grands événements
de plus de 2000 personnes voici qu'il
concerne depuis août dernier un nombre
incalculable d'actes de la vie
quotidienne et on nous propose
aujourd'hui de le prolonger jusqu'en
février voir jusqu'à fin juillet 2022 le
respect de la parole publique doit plus
que jamais reprendre son sens dans notre
pays et compte tenu de la situation
actuelle le maintien du Pass ne me
paraît pas justifié tel est l'objet de
cet amendement merci chers collègues
l'amendement 54 n'est pas défendu il
tombe l'amendement 65 madame monsieur
gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues on rentre
dans les amendements de replis donc
notre porte le premier sur un certain
nombre d'établissements type médiathèque
ou bibliothèque et puis je profite
monsieur le ministre puisque notre
collègue avait raison tout à l'heure
peut-être qu'il peut avoir ce qu'on
appelle un effet de bord un certain
relâchement sur les gestes barrières ça
c'est une réalité donc je pense qu'on
aurait besoin d'une très grande campagne
là de communication et de mobilisation
autour des gestes barrières à poursuivre
et je vous pose une question monsieur
j'ai amené mon fils au cinéma ce
week-end et j'ai été extrêmement surpris
d'une chose évidemment pas sanitaire
mais ensuite
ce qui était affiché ce n'est plus
masque obligatoire mais masque
recommandés et donc qui a eu pour effet
de suite que lorsque les gens ont
visionné ça certains membres abandonné
le masque puisqu'il n'était plus
obligatoire il devenait recommandé donc
là par exemple on aurait vocation plutôt
à avoir un masque obligatoire dans un
lieu clos et peut-être pour le coup
relâcher sur la question du Pass
sanitaire je vous remercie
l'amendement 41 c'est madame de La
gantille
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement et pour nous un amendement
clé sur lequel je l'indique comme je
l'ai indiqué comme mission des lois
notre groupe demandera un scrutin public
cet amendement poursuit la logique qui
est de dire nous ne pouvons pas
appliquer le Pass sanitaire partout et
dans toutes les dans tous les
départements de France car la situation
vaccinale n'est pas la même nous
demandons donc que dès lors que 80% de
la population éligible d'un département
sera vacciné le passe sanitaire ne sera
plus nécessaire cela correspond et cela
correspondra mi-novembre à la totalité
des départements français alors vous
allez assister dans quelques instants à
une discussion entre les uns et les
autres que je pourrais qualifier de
manière un peu triviale de marchand de
tapis
sauf que de deux choses l'une où nous
considérons que le Pass sanitaire en
métropole n'a plus de raison d'être
parce que plus de 80% de la population
est vaccinée et nous le disons
ou alors nous allons proposer des
chiffres qui vont être très complexes à
appréhender car ils sont eux-mêmes pas
toujours connus donc vous l'avez compris
notre groupe en fait un point central et
c'est de l'adoption ou non de cet
amendement que dépendra notre position
sur l'ensemble du texte merci amendement
17 de Monsieur benaroche
tout à l'heure en fait le taux de
vaccination pour nous n'est pas probant
voilà ça ne peut pas être critère ça
peut pas être ce qui va servir à
déterminer dans un cadre repli du passe
sanitaire ça ne peut pas servir donc il
y a eu des amendements Assemblée
nationale il y en a un qui parlait de
taux d'incidence
ça nous paraît déjà pas qu'à nous d'une
manière globale additionner le taux
d'incidence à la vaccination tu es déjà
pas mal bon pour autant est-ce qu'on
tient le sésame absolu qui nous
permettrait de dire ben là on va mettre
pas et puis là on va pas en mettre
non parce qu'il y a un troisième taux
aussi qui est mis en avant maintenant
qui sortent d'ailleurs encore plus
pertinent c'est le taux de
reproductivité effectif c'est à celui
avec lequel le virus se reproduirait et
ça ça apporte une donnée qui apparaît
plus pertinente mais qui constitue pas
pour autant un absolu alors pourquoi
cette démonstration simplement parce
qu'il me semble d'une manière claire
qu'aujourd'hui on nous ne pouvons pas
définir clairement avec un critère
universel admis partout au regard de la
situation sanitaire qui est la nôtre
avec une immunité déclinante puisque le
il y a deux vaccins et on sait très bien
que certains ont été fait le deuxième
dose depuis longtemps et avec l'inconnu
face à de possibles variants je ne vois
pas comment à part dans une discussion
de marchands tapis comme la plaie à
l'instant madame de La Gautherie nous
pourrions arriver à déterminer à quel
endroit il faudrait à passer sanitaire
dans quelle ville dans quel département
dans quelle commune dans quelle région
donc elle était à quel endroit il n'en
faudrait pas donc cet abonnement de
repli de repli que nous proposons pour
dire mais
le taux de reproductivité de ce décan
d'abonnement qui tente à prouver et à
vous dire non c'est le Pass sanitaire
lui-même qui doit être mis en cause
aujourd'hui dans la situation sanitaire
où nous sommes n'essayons pas de trouver
un possible accord avec le gouvernement
qui vient de nous montrer qu'il est
impossible dans une conviction Biggs
paritaire improbable ou parce que nous
aurions des chiffres par département
nous pourrions d'un seul coup trouver un
accord ne suivons pas cela ne continuons
pas cette chimère cher comme
l'avant de 49 monsieur Bascher
oui merci monsieur le Président à
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est d'abord un amendement de mon
collègue Cédric Vial nous avons un peu
travaillé justement non pas sur des
erreurs statistiques ou des marchands
tapis que je trouve un petit peu
méprisant madame de La Gontrie je me
permets de vous le dire mais 75% nous
nous proposons 80% de la population
éligible à la vaccination cas de qui
parle-t-on de quoi parle-t-on voilà ce
que propose le premier amendement et si
monsieur le Président de LACORE je vais
présenter aussi le suivant le 51
rectifié qui est semble quelque chose
peut-être de plus simple et plus clair
qui est de remplacer le taux de 75% par
70 % pourquoi 70% c'est certain
amendements de repli mais c'est quand
même 80 c'est là correspond en vérité à
90% de la population de plus de 18 ans
donc comme c'est bien l'objectif il me
semble que c'est amendement celui-ci
donc le 51
rectifier quater me semble le plus
important à adopter merci chers
collègues le 58 madame Miller Brown
monsieur le ministre cher collègue alors
il s'agit de remplacer les mots un taux
d'incidence par les mots un taux élevé
d'incidence de la maladie covid-19
aujourd'hui le virus du strass covid 2
tend à devenir endémique un taux
d'incidence non défini ne renseigne pas
finement sur la nature de la circulation
virale ni sur l'apparition de la maladie
d'une part le taux de positivité des
tests de dépistage renseignent sur les
présences de génome de virus et non sur
la présence d'un virus viable et
infectieux un test de dépistage dissocié
d'une symptomatologie maladie ne donne
pas d'indication sur la situation
épidémiologique le système Sentinel
existe il a été mis de côté dans le
pilotage de la politique sanitaire
depuis des mois et c'est inadmissible
de plus le taux de positivité présente
deux limites le nombre de tests réalisés
le dénominateur commun dans le cadre
d'une épidémie seule un nombre de
positifs sur nombre d'habitants seraient
représentatif d'autre part la couverture
vaccinale est indépendante de la
positivité au test de dépistage et de la
pathologie on peut être porteur malade
transmetteur avec la couverture
vaccinale élevée des exemples en milieu
clos les prisons ou dans des pays avec
80% de vaccinés montrent que la
circulation épidémique peut être
contrôlée en Suède par exemple ou
évolutive en Israël ou Singapour
indépendamment de la couverture atteinte
la vaccination avec les vaccins covid-19
actuellement proposés n'est pas un
indicateur de la situation épidémique ou
de sa maîtrise et donc le Pass sanitaire
ne se justifie pas merci
42 madame de La Gontrie
merci monsieur le Président dans la
rédaction qui a été adoptée par la
commission il est prévu de prévoir à la
fois un taux de vaccination population
globale de 75% et ces cumulatif dans
lequel une circulation active du virus
est constatée mesurée par un taux
d'incidence élevé l'expression est floue
et donc nous proposons par cet
amendement de dire les choses de manière
nette et de remplacer les termes taux
d'incidence élevées par supérieur ou
égal à 50% mille pour une habitant pour
sur une durée continue de moins 7 jours
car ce qu'il faut c'est que nos
concitoyens savent très clairement quels
sont les règles qui sont appliquées
merci chers collègues trois amendements
identiques le 30 madame Noël
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis le
30 septembre le Pass est obligatoire
pour les mineurs de 12 à 17 ans
conditionnant l'accès à de nombreuses
activités
qui s'exerce à géométrie très variable
ainsi par exemple les enfants
fréquentant une école de musique portée
par une collectivité seront exemptés du
Pass pendant que ceux dont l'école de
musique est associative devront de
justifier du précieux sésame des
exemples comme celui-ci sont très
nombreux générant autant de frustrations
doublées d'un sentiment profond
d'injustice au-delà de ces incohérences
cet amendement vise à interdire le Pass
sanitaire pour les mineurs pour des
questions de santé et d'éthique
conformément aux préconisations du
Comité national d'éthique dont le
président Jean-François d'être aussi
déclarait je cite le Pass sanitaire ne
doit pas concerner les enfants et les
adolescents le recul existant ne permet
pas d'assurer la pleine sécurité de ces
nouveaux vaccins chez l'adolescent les
conséquences de la pandémie sur la santé
psychologique et mentale des enfants et
surtout des adolescents sont profondes
et probablement durable s'agissant de
l'immunité collective est-il éthique de
faire supporter au mineur la
responsabilité en termes de bénéfices
collectif du refus de la vaccination
d'une partie de la population adulte
pour toutes ces raisons il convient de
mettre en termes au Pass sanitaire des
mineurs merci le 57
identiques madame Delmont coropolis
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement tant à exempter les mineurs
du Pass sanitaire en effet depuis les
débuts de la crise en mars 2020 les
mineurs avec les personnes âgées sont
les populations qui ont le plus souffert
de l'isolement contrairement aux
personnes âgées les mineurs citoyens en
devenir ayant besoin d'interagir pour se
construire sont les personnes les moins
vulnérables à l'épidémie en effet pour
cette tranche d'âge le taux de cas
graves suivi médicalement est inférieur
à 1% et le taux de décès frôle 0% dans
le même temps la couverture vaccinale à
85% de la population est suffisamment
protectrice pour protéger les adultes il
de rendre à chacun la maîtrise de sa
santé en collaboration avec son médecin
et sans pharmacien continuez dans
l'incitation à la vaccination des
enfants par l'obligation du Pass
sanitaire pour les 12-18 ans
décritibiliserait fortement la parole
politique pour ces raisons c'est
amendement vise à sortir luminaire des
dispositifs liés au passataire
si chers collègues de 59 madame Müller
Braun
identique
monsieur le Président merci c'est
amendement propose de ne pas soumettre
au Pass sanitaire les jeunes de moins de
18 ans afin qu'ils ne soient pas exclus
des activités scolaires sportives et
culturelles en effet d'une part le taux
de vaccination des 12-18 ans est déjà
très élevée et d'autre part le vaccin
n'ayant pas démontré d'efficacité totale
dans la transmission du virus il n'est
plus nécessaire aujourd'hui de prolonger
la pression vaccinale par ailleurs
plusieurs études récentes font état de
risque avérés de complications cardiaque
chez les jeunes de moins de 18 ans par
ailleurs le Parlement n'a reçu aucune
information de la part du gouvernement
sur l'intégration de la troisième dose
au Pass sanitaire quand sera-t-il si
elle est tactée pour les plus de 65 ans
comme le ministre de la Santé l'a
indiqué en audition le 26 octobre déjà
il a également précisé que des études
sont en cours pour intégrer la troisième
dose au Pass sanitaire selon les
comorbidités ainsi des adolescents en
surpoids par exemple pourrait être
contraint de recevoir une troisième
injection pour conserver leur passe or
il est inacceptable d'envisager une
telle mesure non seulement discriminante
mais dangereuse pour la santé mentale et
physique des adolescents cette catégorie
atteint déjà un taux de vaccination
élevé tandis que la stratégie sanitaire
du gouvernement a échoué depuis 8 mois à
aller vers les 2,2 millions de personnes
fragiles merci chers
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement est un amendement de repli
qui a défaut d'un changement de
paradigme vis-à-vis du Pass sanitaire
que nous avons souhaité mettre en oeuvre
vis-à exclure son usage pour les
activités de loisirs qui ont lieu en
extérieur pour le réserver à celle qui
se tiennent en lieu clos en effet les
membres du groupe socialiste estime
qu'en période de maîtrise de l'épidémie
les activités planaires doivent rester
accessibles à tous et dans les mêmes
conditions il s'agit notamment de
recréer du lien social là où il a été
brisé tout en continuant à assurer une
lutte efficace et raisonnée contre la
covid-19 dans cette optique il est
désormais incontesté et incontestable
que le virus se transmet beaucoup moins
en milieu ouvert qu'en milieu clos et
même jusqu'à 18 fois moins selon
plusieurs études menées à l'université
de Berkeley et de San Francisco la
proportionnalité du dispositif du passé
militaire ne doit donc s'envisager qu'à
la lumière de ces éléments et c'est
précisément l'objet de cet amendement
par ailleurs les auteurs de cet
amendement tiennent à rappeler qu'une
telle limitation de l'application du
Pass sanitaire ne doit empêcher ni le
respect des gestes barrières ni le port
du masque qui reste obligatoire
merci chers collègues l'amendement 1
madame Noël
oui merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues je défends ici l'avant
de mon collègue Michel Savin qui
considère à juste titre qu'il a un
compréhensible que les adolescents
puissent pratiquer une activité sportive
au collège au lycée en EPS ou bien lors
de leurs activités réalisées avec l'UNSS
et que les mêmes pratiques dans le cadre
associatif souvent dans les mêmes lieux
lorsqu'on interdites s'ils ne présentent
pas de passes sanitaire cet amendement
est donc une mesure de bon sens qui vise
à permettre aux mineurs de continuer à
pratiquer une activité physique et
sportive au sein d'une association
sportive ou d'un club sans avoir à
présenter le Pass la pratique sportive
est un élément majeur pour la santé
publique de nos concitoyens la crise
sanitaire a profondément affecté la
pratique des Français notamment des plus
jeunes le renforcement de la sédentarité
est un véritable problème de santé
publique il convient de combattre
vivement par ailleurs les retours
concernant les inscriptions dans les
associations sportives en ce début
d'année montrent que les mineurs de 12 à
18 ans se sont éloignés de la pratique
quand le retour en club des moins de 12
ans est extrêmement dynamique
le deuxième donc toujours un amendement
de Michel Savin cet amendement de vis a
exempté les mineurs de la présentation
du Pass sanitaire pour accéder aux
bibliothèques le service public des
bibliothèques est reconnu comme
essentiel et la proposition de loi
relative au bibliothèque et au
développement de la lecture publique
récemment adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale et en cours de navettes
parlementaires reconnaît l'importance de
ces lieux des villes ont d'ores et déjà
fait le choix d'exemples et l'accès aux
bibliothèques de contrôle de passes
sanitaire si cela se fait dans le cadre
scolaire ou universitaire afin d'offrir
un excès libre à la culture de tous les
jeunes il confirme donc d'exempter les
mineurs de tout contrôle sanitaire pour
l'accès à ces espaces de culture merci
chers collègues le 60 Monsieur Arnaud
oui monsieur le président
j'ai été saisi par un maire qui m'a dit
la chose suivante je m'adresse à toi
comme sénateur les biotech ont
obligation de contrôle du poste
sanitaire pour les usagers comme tu le
sais dans tous nos petits villages les
biotech municipales ne peuvent exister
que grâce au bénévoles or contenu de
l'interdiction faite alors que ce n'est
pas le cas pour les librairies d'accéder
aux bibliothèque notamment rurales il
n'y a plus de lieux de socialisation au
sein des communes les plus rurales notre
département est de nos territoires
ruraux de France c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous propose à travers cet
amendement à ce que nous puissions
ouvrir à tous les publics les biotechs
sont pas sanitaires en tenant compte que
c'est déjà le cas pour les librairies
qui sont également des supports d'accès
à la lecture voilà en substance et en
quelques mots l'amendement ainsi proposé
donc remplacer les mots lorsque celle
sur les mots à l'exception de l'accès au
biotech lorsque ces activités etc je
vous remercie merci cher collègue le 13
monsieur benaroche
médiathèque des musées en fait puisque
notre amendement parle des trois
soumis à la présentation de pas
sanitaire depuis le mois d'août pour les
personnes âgées de plus de 12 ans et
donc nous demandons en fait en tenant
compte des conditions nécessaires
d'accès au service public pour tous de
l'accès aux services culturel de
proximité du fait que les bibliothèques
les médiathèques et les musées sont des
lieux d'échanges de liens social qui
participent de l'apprentissage et de
l'éducation de nos enfants et des
adolescents et au vu de la situation
sanitaire aujourd'hui et dans le cas où
les gestes barrières sont respectés dans
ces établissements nous pensons et nous
disons qu'il n'est nullement besoin de
conditionner leur accès à la
présentation de passes sanitaire pour
les jeunes mineurs de plus de 12 ans
et le 37 madame prix
monsieur Chantal
oui alors en fait c'est tellement de
monde repli propose de réserver le
recours au poste sanitaire au restaurant
et bars qui dispose d'un espace de
consommation en intérieur il s'agit des
clarté les terrasses de l'obligation de
pas sanitaire et ce pour deux raisons
simples premièrement le taux de
vaccination complète de la population
c'est largement accrue depuis quelques
mois et nous nous en félicitons la
France a en effet été propulsé à la
deuxième place au niveau européen sur le
nombre de doses administrées et à la
neuvième place sur le pourcentage de de
population complètement vaccinée
deuxièmement l'exigence de présentation
d'un Pass sanitaire représente une
charge supplémentaire considérable pour
les restaurateurs qui n'ont pas toujours
les moyens matériels ou humains pour en
assurer le contrôle
cette étape de fait aboutit
inévitablement à des situations ou des
établissements ne sont pas en capacité
de faire respecter l'obligation se
mettant malgré eux en porte-à-faux avec
les obligations légales en vigueur
encore une fois les taux de transmission
étant nettement inférieur en milieu
ouvert les membres de notre groupe
souhaitent améliorer le texte et
restreindre le recours au Pass sanitaire
à l'essentiel merci le 38
vous défendez aussi je vais le défendre
aussi c'est amendement repli prévoit de
de réserver l'exigence de présentation
d'un Pass sanitaire valide uniquement au
foire séminaires et salons
professionnels qui rassemble
simultanément plus de 1000 personnes le
gouvernement et l'Assemblée nationale
ont à plusieurs reprises balayer
l'inscription de Joses applicable au
passes sanitaire dans la loi elles ont
finalement été fixées à 50 personnes par
décret la redéfinition des choses et
leur intégration dans la loi sont
pourtant essentielles pour assurer la la
proportionnalité du dispositif que nous
examinons en particulier dans un
contexte d'alcalmie de l'épidémie la
jauge de 1000 personnes proposées par
ces amendements reprend le seuil qui
avait été initialement institué pour les
grands rassemblements de personnes par
la loi du 31 mai 2021 relative à la
gestion de sorties de la crise sanitaire
avant d'être élargi par la loi du 5 août
dernier en contradiction avec les
assurances du président de la République
sur ce sujet en outre il s'agit d'un
seuil cohérent envers Cu de des
recommandations qu'avaient émises la
mission commune d'information pour la
réouverture des lieux culturels qui
préconisaient d'adapter les les jauges
par palier successifs en fonction du
volume de la disposition et des
conditions de ventilation des locaux ou
des espaces merci chers collègues le 66
madame kukkermann oui merci
[Musique]
avec cet amendement de repli nous
souhaitons exclure du dispositif de
recours au Pass sanitaire les
professionnels exerçant les
établissements vidés visés pardon et
soumis à la présentation d'un Pass
sanitaire par le public il s'agirait de
cesser de culpabiliser ses
professionnels de les infantiliser les
obligeant à se faire vacciner étant
donné le taux de vaccination atteint en
moyenne sur notre territoire cela n'a
plus vraiment raison d'être à nos yeux
il s'agit par exemple des professionnels
travaillent dans les bibliothèques les
médiathèques les crèches etc comme cela
a déjà été développé et rappelé par
plusieurs de mes collègues précédemment
bien souvent la présentation d'un Pass
sanitaire notamment sur les lieux de
travail entraîne une observation moindre
des gestes barrières port du masque
lavage de main distance de sécurité
entre les uns et les autres tout cela
sous couvert de passes sanitaires
c'est-à-dire dans la plupart des cas de
schémas vaccinal complet mais nous
devons nous devons rappeler que la
vaccination n'empêche pas la
contamination et la transmission du
virus aussi cet effet pervers du passage
sur le relâchement contre gestes
barrière devrait nous interroger sur la
reconduction de son usage notamment au
sein de ces milieux professionnels tel
est l'objet de notre amendement merci
chers
[Musique]
commune
de la Commission
c'est le président tout d'abord
s'agissant de l'amendement numéro 6 de
Monsieur benaroche je lui ferait
remarqué que
le texte de la commission en réalité
satisfait son amendement parce que la
Commission elle aussi souhaite que là où
les gestes barrières et notamment le
port du masque sont possibles ne pas
sanitaire ne soit en principe pas
appliqué même dans les départements ou
le taux de vaccination est inférieur à
la moyenne nationale donc je vous
propose soit de retirer votre amendement
soit je demanderai au Sénat de voter
contre cet amendement
l'amendement de Madame Delmont coraux
police me paraît être un amendement
prudent que les personnes les plus
vulnérables de notre pays même dans les
départements où la vaccination est
élevée soit spécialement protégée c'est
le cas dans les établissements
médico-sociaux je pense au foyer
d'accueil médicalisé par exemple et donc
la vie est favorable ensuite nous avons
plusieurs
amendements qui subsistent le numéro 7
rectifié le 27 et le 65 qui vise à
supprimer purement et simplement le
passe sanitaire la commission a émis un
avis défavorable elle met le Pass
sanitaire en voie d'extinction à chaque
fois que le département aura un taux de
vaccination qui rejoindra la moyenne
nationale on ne pourra plus utiliser le
Pass sanitaire mais à titre de
transition et pour préparer justement
cette disparition progressive du Pass
sanitaire il nous a semblé nécessaire de
le maintenir dans un certain nombre de
départements où la vaccination est en
retard à vie donc des favorables nous
avons ensuite une série d'amendements
qui ont en commun d'accepter le système
de la commission ça n'est pour certains
d'entre eux pas la voie privilégiée par
leurs auteurs il s'agit alors
d'amendement de repli mais dans tous les
cas ces amendements reflètent un accord
de principe avec une position qui
consiste à maintenir transitoirement le
Pass sanitaire là où la vaccination est
en retard le seul désaccord avec la
commission c'est d'une part sur le seuil
de vaccination à partir duquel le passe
sanitaire devient impossible et d'autre
part c'est la prise en compte ou non et
selon des rédactions d'ailleurs
différentes de l'autre critères que
celui de la vaccination c'est-à-dire le
critère de circulation très active du
virus la Commission souhaite que le
critère de circulation très actif du
virus soit maintenu car c'est une
condition supplémentaire mise à la
prolongation du Pass sanitaire dans les
départements où la vaccination est en
retard et la Commission souhaite aussi
que le qu'elle a retenu et qui n'est pas
improvisé soit maintenu ce chiffre de
75% correspond exactement à la moyenne
nationale vous êtes dans la moyenne
nationale ou mieux que la moyenne
nationale plus de passe sanitaire vous
êtes en dessous de la moyenne nationale
vous devrez attendre pour que le Pass
sanitaire soit levé que le taux de
vaccination est rejoint la moyenne
nationale ça nous paraît cohérent
toutefois si vous n'étiez pas de cet
avis je crois que nous allons pas avoir
nous n'allons pas avoir entre nous une
dispute sur le point de savoir s'il faut
conserver le taux de 75%, ou sera lié à
un taux mettons de 70% de la population
totale et par conséquent la commission a
émis un avis de sagesse sur l'un de ses
amendements elle ne souhaite pas qu'il
soit adopté mais elle veut se
réconciliante et cet amendement c'est
celui de Monsieur Cédric Vial qui porte
le numéro 51 et qui
modifie le chiffre en passant de 75% de
la population vaccinée à 70 à 75% de la
population vaccinée on est à peu près à
une couverture vaccinale de 88 % de la
population de plus de 12 ans à 70% on se
trouve autour de 80% dans les deux cas
on se rapproche de ce qui pourrait être
une illimité collective tout en te
connaissant d'ailleurs pas le chiffre
qui est nous permettrait de donner la
garantie de l'immunité collective mais
on se rapproche dans les deux cas je
crois que la position de la Commission
est plus prudente mais la position de
cet amendement n'est pas impossible je
vous suggère en votre âme et conscience
de vous prononcer sur ce point vous
ayant indiqué quelle était ma préférence
et je pense que nos collègues qui ont
présenté et soutenu l'amendement numéro
41 pourraient par bonne volonté se
rapprocher que cette solution dès lors
que leur position à eux est en réalité
un taux de 68% 68% 70%, est-ce que ça
mérite une dispute entre nous je ne le
crois pas enfin nous avons maintenant
une série d'amendements dans le premier
celui de Madame Laurence Müller Braun le
numéro 58 c'est un amendement de
précision qui nous a paru utile c'est la
raison pour laquelle la Commission lui a
donné un avis favorable l'amendement
numéro
42 de Madame de La Gontrie nous n'y
sommes pas favorables mais c'est un
amendement qui veut au fond préciser
exactement à partir de quel taux
d'incidence du virus on pourrait
rétablir le Pass sanitaire dans un
département où la vaccination est en
retard sur la moyenne nationale nous
nous sommes bornés à renvoyer la
décision gouvernement en mentionnant un
taux de circulation du virus très élevé
bon je crois qu'il faut laisser quand
même une marge de manœuvre au
gouvernement la vie défavorable vous
avez pas une question de principe pour
nous c'est une question de réglage enfin
nous avons jeudi enfin non j'anticipe
nous avons ensuite des amendements
identiques ils visent à ce que les
mineurs de moins de 18 ans
soit exemptés quel que soit le lieu où
ils habitent de l'obligation de
présenter le Pass sanitaire quand ils
sortent dans des lieux collectifs mes
chers collègues je vous inciterai à la
prudence sur ces amendements pour
lesquels la commission a émis un avis de
demande de retrait ou alors la vie devra
malheureusement être défavorable
n'oublions pas que nous avons une sorte
d'obligation de cohérence avec nous-même
nous avons au mois de juillet dernier
prix des mesures pour favoriser la
vaccination des plus de 12 ans nous
avons prévu par exemple qu'entre 16 et
18 ans le jeune peut décider tout seul
de se vacciner nous avons même prévu
qu'entre 12 et 18 ans un seul des
parents aurait à autoriser la
vaccination pourquoi avons-nous fait
cela c'est parce que il y a quelques
mois nous avons été convaincus que même
si
le risque vital pour un mineur de 12 à
18 ans est évidemment très faible il y a
aussi les covidons il y a aussi le fait
qu'ils peuvent être malades et que la
vaccination présente pour eux aussi un
bilan coût avantage dans lequel on peut
considérer que les avantages l'emporte
et puis surtout
un
mineur contagieux peut contaminer autour
de lui énormément de personnes or on
fait des moyennes
par rapport à la population sur la
vaccination mais enfin nous avons quand
même un certain nombre de départements
dans lesquels la vaccination est très en
retard alors je crois que il ne faut pas
complètement oublier la prise en compte
des mineurs dans le processus de
vaccination dont je rappelle que la
vaccination bien sûr n'est absolument
pas obligatoire d'ailleurs nous sommes
également
fermes sur nos principes quand il s'agit
de ne pas divulguer les secrets médicaux
de nos de nos écoliers de nos collégiens
de nos lycéens aux administrations des
établissements d'enseignements pour
toutes ces raisons je vous demanderai
mes chers collègues de bien vouloir
renoncer à votre à vos amendements pour
lesquels sinon la commission émettrait
un avis défavorable
madame de La Gonterie a présenté
l'amendement numéro 36 qui vise à
exempter l'obligation de passe sanitaire
là où elle existe pour les activités de
loisirs en extérieur madame de La
Gonterie nous sommes favorables à votre
amendement de même que nous sommes
favorables à l'amendement de Monsieur
Savin pour les associations sportives
qui vont avoir des organisé des
activités dans le gymnase du collège
alors quand ces activités sportives ont
lieu dans le cadre scolaire avec un
professeur d'éducation physique et
sportive pas besoin de pas sanitaire au
même endroit avec un animateur socio
sportifs il faudra le Pass sanitaire non
je crois que cet amendement est bien
inspiré dans la mesure où il permet
d'unifier le régime de taxer à des
activités dans un même lieu scolaire
même quand elles ne sont pas de nature
scolaire monsieur Savin va plus loin il
voudrait que on fasse la même chose pour
les bibliothèques mais monsieur ça va je
vous pas de retirer votre amendement
parce que le problème est réglé par
ailleurs puisque comme je l'indiquais à
propos d'un précédent amendement nous
n'avons pas prévu de pas sanitaire dans
les bibliothèques puisque on peut très
bien aller lire des livres vous
feuilleter des magazines avec un masque
en revanche on ne peut pas manger ni
boire avec un masque et ce critère de
bon sens fait la distinction entre les
lieux où le Pass sanitaire continuera à
être possible dans certains départements
et les lieux où il deviendra impossible
nous avons maintenant un amendement
numéro 60 de Monsieur Arnaud et un
amendement 13 de Monsieur benaroche pour
les mêmes raisons ces amendements me
paraissent et paraissent satisfait à la
commission madame de La Gontrie vous
revenez sur un débat que nous avons eu
déjà vous voudriez fixer un nombre de
personnes à partir duquel on imposerait
le passe sanitaire le débat est un débat
très intéressant parce qu'on se dit
comme ça les petits événements on
élimine l'obligation du spasme mais je
voudrais vous faire quand même
observer que le problème de la
contamination n'est pas lié au nombre de
personnes un nombre élevé de personnes
dans un très grand espace n'est pas une
source de risque un nombre élevé de
personnes dans un petit espace le
devient en réalité le vrai critère c'est
pas le nombre de personnes c'est la
promiscuité comme vous êtes tout prêt
les uns des autres vous vous exposez à
un risque de contamination ça c'est vrai
pour toutes les maladies virales et
toutes les épidémies par conséquent je
ne crois pas que ce soit réellement
utile de fixer un nombre de personnes
dans un même lieu tout dépend de la
surface et donc de la promiscuité enfin
le 66 mes chers collègues le 66 veut
c'est il est présenté par Madame assassy
et ses collègues il voudrait que on
supprime l'exigence du pas sanitaire
pour les personnels dans les
établissements où le public ne peut
accéder sans passer sanitaire non je
crois qu'il faut harmoniser si le public
doit être sélectionner en fonction de
son statut vaccinal ou de son statut
viral il faut que le personnel le soit
aussi je crois que c'est d'une logique
un placable voilà monsieur le Président
et mes chers collègues les avis de la
commission des lois c'est monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président
vous voulez compléter ses avis ou non je
suis pas compléter les avis mais
justement parce qu'ils ont été donnés la
Commission souhaiterait demande
au Sénat que l'amendement numéro 51
rectifié soit voté par priorité avant
l'amendement numéro 41 de notre collègue
Bernard jaumier s'il vous plaît merci
[Musique]
donc je demanderai l'accord de
gouvernement sur sur cette demande la
vie du gouvernement sur cette priorité
et monsieur le ministre vous êtes
favorable
donc elle est de droite à cette priorité
donc l'amendement 51 sera voté avant
l'amendement 41
monsieur le ministre votre avis sur sur
tous ces amendements
[Musique]
le masque c'est un avis défavorable sur
le 6
rectifié madame Delmont corropolis ça
sera également un avis favorable à
l'image de la vie de la de la Commission
sur votre amendement qui vise à rétablir
la possibilité d'imposer sur l'ensemble
du territoire le passé militaire pour
accéder aux établissements de santé
sociaux et médico-sociaux il revient
donc pour ce cas précis sur sur le
principe de territorialisation en
réalité en fonction de la couverture
vaccinale au niveau du département qui
était imposé par le texte de vaccination
et donc à cet égard et parce que cela
concerne aussi les personnes les plus
vulnérables comme la évoqué le
rapporteur nous sommes favorables à
cette amendement qui contribue en
réalité à rendre au passes sanitaire son
périmètre initial donc certaines formes
de cohérence et je me permets de saisir
cette occasion pour rappeler de manière
plus générale les raisons pour
lesquelles à l'inverse le gouvernement
ne souhaite pas souhaitable de fixer
dans la loi un seuil territorialisé de
vaccination au-delà duquel le Pass ne
pourrait plus être mise en oeuvre
premièrement car une telle
territorialisation imposée par référence
à un seuil rigide est incompatible avec
la réactivité faiblesses nécessaires
pour prendre rapidement des mesures qui
soient adaptées et proportionnelles à
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire et
le passé nous a montré que cette
évolution de situation pouvait être
extrêmement rapide deuxièmement pour des
raisons de sécurité juridique également
il est impossible d'estimer avec une
précision suffisante le nombre de
personnes vaccinées pour faire du taux
de vaccination un critère chiffré de
déclenchement du passe
je donne un exemple concret j'étais
hier encore dans un de nos départements
frontaliers
où il y a beaucoup de travailleurs
frontaliers qui donc ont été se faire
vacciner de l'autre côté de la de la
frontière et qui ne sont pas forcément
comptabilisés dans nos chiffres et donc
qui rendent difficile c'est un exemple
cette cette faculté de déterminer avec
précision le nombre de personnes
vaccinées et donc de l'inscrire dans la
loi donc véritable problème de sécurité
juridique et enfin la fixation d'un
seuil rigide territorialisé ignore les
déplacements des personnes alors qu'un
département peut accueillir un nombre
important notamment pour des motifs
professionnels ou alors que la période
estivale pourra enfin se présentera
devant nous comme ça a été évoqué mais
néanmoins je le rappelle c'est un avis
favorable monsieur le Président sur cet
amendement amendement numéro 5
l'ensemble des
oui je suis je ne suis qu'au début
l'ensemble des amendements qui visent à
supprimer le Pass sanitaire le 7
rectifié le 27 le 54 rectifier le 65 ça
sera un avis défavorable du gouvernement
vous vous rappelez ou vous partagez la
situation du Danemark
qui est aussi un couverture vaccinale
proche voir légèrement supérieur à un
autre plus de 75% de la population
qui a décidé de supprimer l'application
du Pass sanitaire et dont la circulation
du virus remonte en et le nombre de
personnes contaminées remontent en
flèche voilà donc toute disposition qui
vise à supprimer ce Pass fatal que le
propose ses amendements
recueille un avis défavorable de la part
du gouvernement
s'agissant
de l'ensemble des amendements qui visent
à
changer les critères qui avait établi la
commission que ça soit sur le
pourcentage de la population éligible à
la vaccination
substitution d'un critère d'incidence
autour de vaccination je parle donc des
des amendements 41 51
rectifiés l'amendement 17 de Monsieur
benaroche l'amendement
49 rectifiés je vérifie de ne pas vous
dire de bêtises ou encore le 58 de
Madame Müller Brown et je pense que le
42 de Madame de La Gonterie rentre
également dans cette catégorie là ça
sera des avis défavorables du
gouvernement vous l'avez compris
globalement le gouvernement défend la
nécessité d'avoir une pluralité de
critères prises en compte afin de
déterminer les mesures qui doivent être
prises en considération et de ne pas
inscrire dans la loi des critères
rigides qui nous empêcheraient de faire
face rapidement à la situation à
l'évaluation de la situation donc des
avis défavorables sur l'ensemble de ces
de ces amendements
sur la question des mineurs ça a été
assez bien explicité défendu par le
rapporteur ça sera également des avis
défavorables de la part du gouvernement
vous dire que
le taux de transexibilité du variant du
variant delta est autour de 8 ce qui
fait que le
la cible d'immunité populationnelle
est autour de 90% et que pour atteindre
cette cible d'immunité populationnelle
collective nous avons besoin que soit
vacciné les mineurs de entre 12 et 17
ans ils sont je crois de mémoire 76%
aujourd'hui dans notre pays à avoir un
schéma vaccinal complet ce vaccin de
plus en plus sans que cela ne pose de
problème particulier sachez aussi
que le sous variant Delta dont on
commence à parler qui est présent en
Grande-Bretagne
représenterait représenterait je mets ça
au conditionnel un taux de
transmissibilité près de 15% supérieur à
la souche initiale du variant du variant
Delta tel que nous la connaissons et qui
est présent je crois à 100% quasiment
dans notre pays aujourd'hui donc soyons
là aussi extrêmement prudent et
laissons-nous les outils pour pouvoir
réagir à la situation auquel nous
pouvons être confrontés s'agissant de
l'amendement numéro 36 de Madame de La
Gonterie qui vise à ne pas appliquer le
Pass sanitaire aux espaces extérieurs
pour les activités de loisirs et qui a
reçu un amendement de mémoire favorable
de la part de la Commission ça sera un
amendement défavorable de la part du
gouvernement
sanitaire permet de garantir le maintien
de l'ouverture des lieux dans lesquels
il s'applique tout en prêtéant les
personnes contre la liste de
contamination même s'ils sont moins
importants ces risques que pour les
activités intérieures ces risques de
contamination ils existent toutes même
en extérieur et les activités de loisirs
donnent lieu à des brassages de
population la densité des personnes
accueillies peut-être importantes et les
gestes barrières comme vous les signer
ne pas être forcément toujours respecté
même s'ils nous allons rappeler
l'importance par ailleurs des
observations sur le variant Delta tente
à montrer qu'il génère davantage de
contamination en extérieur que les
autres souches que nous avons pu
connaître par le passé c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes opposés à cet
amendement numéro 36
s'agissant du 1 rectifié de Monsieur
Savin juste en réponse aux arguments
développés par le monsieur par monsieur
le rapporteur sur ce gymnase qui
permettrait d'un côté de que des
activités soient pratiquées et pas de
l'autre oui mais dans un cas il s'agit
du cadre scolaire et nous avons tout
fait depuis le début pour ne pas
empêcher l'accès aux activités scolaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle le Pass
n'est pas demandé dans ce dans ce cadre
là mais qu'il demeure demandait dans
d'autres dans d'autres cadres même si
c'est le même lieu mais ce n'est pas
dans un cadre scolaire comme vous l'avez
dit vous-même et c'est cohérent avec la
politique que nous menons vis-à-vis de
l'école pour toutes les bonnes raisons
que nous que nous savons c'est donc un
avis chacun sa cohérence voilà c'est un
avis défavorable donc pour rester en
cohérence sur le 1 rectifier
de la même façon sur le de rectifier
le 60 et le 13 qui concerne l'accès aux
mineurs au bibliothèques ou aux
médiathèque là aussi
par cohérence avec effectivement vous
l'avez très bien dit monsieur le
rapporteur les mesures qui ont été
prises pour faciliter la vaccination des
mineurs vous l'avez rappelé
autorité
possibilité
au dessus de entre 16 et 18 ans de
décider seul c'était un amendement de
mémoire de Madame Rossignol de pouvoir
décider seul de se faire vacciner et la
l'autorité parentale d'un seul des deux
parents pour la vaccination des enfants
entre 11 et 17 ans
s'agissant enfin des amandes de
l'amendement numéro 37
et 38 qui portent sur d'une part sur les
espaces extérieurs des restaurants et
des bits de boissons et puis par
ailleurs sur les foires et salons
professionnels de Madame de La Gontrie
sera des avis défavorable du
gouvernement là aussi une fois encore
dans le contexte d'un certain qui est le
qui est le nôtre le Pass sanitaire
permet de garantir le maintien de
l'ouverture des restaurants et des
billes de boissons sans restriction de
jauge tout en protégeant les personnes
contre les risques de contamination qui
existent là aussi tout de même en
extérieur je vous l'ai dit à l'instant
donc avis défavorable pour ces
amendements de même que pour le numéro
53 rectifier de Madame madame Sylvie
Robert sur les établissements voilà
c'est le sur le sur les mineurs et enfin
Madame massassy pour votre amendement
numéro 66 qui vise à supprimer
l'application du Pass sanitaire pour les
professionnels là aussi ils peuvent
contribuer à la circulation du virus à
la contamination dans les établissements
qui reçoivent du public dans lesquels
ils exercent il n'y a aucune
infantilisation madame Dukan ni
culpabilisation de ces professionnels
mais tout comme les personnes qui qui
fréquentent les établissements il est
important que les professionnels qui
exercent soient eux aussi soit eux aussi
soumis à cette obligation ce sera donc
également un avis défavorable sur cette
dernièrement de Madame assassy le
Ministre pour expliquer
le président monsieur le ministre
c'est bien compliqué tout ça
est-ce qu'on peut faire encore confiance
au gouvernement
tous ces mensonges
tous ces revirements
tous ces toutes ces prévisions à
l'armiste où on change les critères pour
être encore plus alarmant
je voudrais revenir sur la pression
vaccinale sur les enfants sur les
mineurs
en médecine quand on parle de
médicaments ou de vaccins on applique le
principe du bénéfice risque le bénéfice
du vaccin pour un mineur il est
quasiment nul si le mineur n'a pas de
morbidité par contre le risque et on
commence à le voir de plus en plus le
risque qu'il existe
le risque qu'il existe à court terme un
moyen terme ou à long terme et faire
porter un risque vaccinal un mineur
qui n'en a pas s'il n'est pas vacciné je
trouve ça grave la vie d'un mineur comme
la vie humaine est très importante et je
voudrais revenir sur l'amendement qui
m'a fait beaucoup plaisir c'est
l'amendement 66
défendu pour madame cukermann
qui concerne les soignants et je
voudrais revenir comme l'a dit Madame de
La conquise sur le mépris du ministre de
la Santé par son absence et le mépris de
ce ministre quand il se régissait
récemment d'avoir forcé des soignants à
se faire vacciner et à l'avoir fait
céder
j'ai reçu un ma permanence des soignants
non vaccinés qui sont suspendus sans
aucune compensation
sans aucune compensation et avec
beaucoup avec de l'inhumanité et du
harcèlement
on le refuse au nom d'une politique
vaccinale qui n'est plus scientifique
mais idéologique nos services hôpitaux
20% de nos services sont fermés il faut
contenir nos services ont besoin de leur
soignante merci Monsieur Richard
c'est le Président le ministre mes chers
collègues difficile d'intervenir en deux
minutes dans une discussion commune à 27
amendements je vais donc aller à
l'essentiel pour ma part je voterai pour
les amendements supprimant les alinéas 6
à 13 car comme je l'ai déjà dit il me
paraît utile de sortir désormais de
l'obligation du passe sanitaire
certes un premier pas a été fait dans
cette direction par monsieur le
rapporteur Philippe Bas mais à travers
une territorialisation dont on le voit
avec les amendements déposés à cet égard
et dont on a déjà commencé à parler
c'est d'ailleurs pas terminé les
critères sont flous et donc propre à
permettre toutes les interprétations par
ceux qui auront à mettre ce passe en
œuvre afin d'éviter les inévitables
difficultés de mise en oeuvre qui
interviendront les préfets naturellement
se substituer en gouvernement à cet
égard territoire par territoire pourquoi
ne pas mettre fin à ce Pass dans la
mesure où la situation familiale
sa situation sanitaire s'améliore
on est loin de la situation de juillet
août dernier où je me souviens on nous
parlait d'un virus à charge mille fois
supérieur à ce que l'on a vécu moi je
tremblais et c'est pour ça que je me
suis abstenu à l'époque bien on en est
plus là maintenant et la vaccination est
arrivée par ailleurs le gouvernement ne
veut pas de cette territorialisation il
a indiqué par deux à deux reprises deux
ministres à l'instant ne pas vouloir
changer d'avis alors
puisqu'il n'y finait monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues nous
n'aurons pas cette territorialisation
deux solutions s'offrent à nous ou
maintenir se passe ou y mettre fin dès
aujourd'hui pour ma part je choisis d'y
mettre fin car je le répète la situation
actuelle n'a plus rien de comparable
avec celle de la mise en vigueur en
début août dernier
rappelez-vous les risques étaient
énormes à l'époque ils sont moindres
aujourd'hui je pense qu'avec une
obligation de gestes barrière on doit
pouvoir s'en sortir comme on s'en est
sorti les fois précédentes je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président je ne
voudrais pas interrompre monsieur
lévrier qu'il est venu s'excuser auprès
du groupe communiste mais je j'entends
au-delà de la blague j'entends les
efforts et les propositions qui sont
faites par la commission pour mettre en
voie d'extinction le Pass sanitaire pour
reprendre vos propos monsieur le
rapporteur
vous avez été enfin vous m'avez en
partie éclairée parce que j'avoue que
j'y perdais un peu mon latin entre 75%
de la population totale 80% de la
population éligible le diable se cache
parfois dans les détails j'en conviens
mais vous avez effectivement dit qu'il
s'agissait de 75 % parce que c'était la
moyenne nationale c'est un critère comme
un autre mais pour moi il n'est pas
opérant au sens où cette moyenne masque
des différences parfois énormes dans un
taux de vaccination des différences qui
peuvent s'exprimer de manière sociale on
voit qu'au sein d'un même département
entre certaines communes il y a des
grosses différences de vaccination qu'on
peut expliquer les sociologues font très
bien d'ailleurs par des critères sociaux
mais aussi par je dirais une approche
plus culturelle par la présence de
soignants sur le territoire ou à
l'inverse par des déserts médicaux par
le fait que parce que dans ceux ne sont
pas encore vaccinés aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de nos anciens qui n'ont par
exemple pas accès facilement à Internet
et le fait d'avoir sous-traiter la
vaccination à des plateformes dont je
tirais le nom ici mais tout le monde
voit bien ce que je veux dire plutôt que
de l'avoir fait par l'assurance maladie
a aussi des conséquences et donc si
l'objectif est de poursuivre la
vaccination pour atteindre un taux
encore plus important on voit bien que
ça n'est pas le Pass qui va le permettre
mais que c'est des réponses d'une autre
nature d'ailleurs pour terminer il faut
aussi avoir en tête qui a un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens qui ne vont
pas très souvent au restaurant jamais au
théâtre exceptionnellement au cinéma et
que pour eux aussi le Pass n'est en
aucun cas
une incitation à la vaccination merci
monsieur ozouyas
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais je vais parler de votre
département les Hauts-de-Seine vous
savez c'est un département ma collègue
Céline brûlante le design instant dans
dans lequel il y a d'énormes distorsions
de vaccination dans les communes
populaires le taux de vaccination est un
peu supérieur à 50% dans d'autres
communes comme dans celle de Neuilly par
exemple il est au-dessus de 80%. donc
bien évidemment personne ne pense ici
que dans les communes populaires vous
avez des gens qui sont dans
l'irrationalité totale et qui sont parce
qu'ils sont pauvres anti-vaccin non la
raison la raison fondamentale c'est que
dans le geste de ce faire vacciner ce
qui est essentiel c'est la confiance et
dans les communes populaires il n'y a
plus de confiance vis-à-vis de l'État il
n'y a plus de confiance de ça vis-à-vis
des services publics parce qu'il y en a
pu et le problème fondamental il est là
alors le taux moyen de vaccination dans
le département
il approche les 75%, mais avec des îlots
ou la vaccination est très faible je
prends je prends l'exemple de de Bagneux
que je que je connais un peu la
Croix-Rouge fait une action extrêmement
forte au pied des tours pour aller
chercher des gens j'ai posé la question
à votre gouvernement comment vous allez
aider financièrement la Croix-Rouge vous
n'avez pas répondu monsieur le ministre
pas vous mais votre votre gouvernement
de toute façon ce qu'on voit bien depuis
six mois c'est que malheureusement dans
ces communes populaires il y a un
plafond de verre c'est à dire que les
vous arrivez à un seuil ou on n'arrive
pas à obtenir une action une vaccination
supplémentaire pourquoi parce que
l'essentiel des personnes qui ne sont
pas vaccinées n'ont pas de vie sociale
et donc le Pass sanitaire sur elle n'a
absolument aucune prise donc ce qu'on
vous demande là maintenant c'est une
politique de santé publique qui va
directement dans les immeubles dans les
cages d'escalier pour aller chercher les
gens là où ils sont sincèrement
sanitaire à montrer son efficacité merci
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
Leconte
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
je suis une petite question à Monsieur
le Ministre parce que nous parlons de
taux de vaccination bon taux de
vaccination ça veut dire
parcours vaccinal complet parcours
vaccinal complet c'est du domaine du
réglementaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
si le gouvernement a l'intention
de considérer que le parcours vaccinal
complet
devra intégrer une troisième dose
d'ici le 31 juillet
et parce que bien entendu tous ces
chiffres évolueront
si c'est le cas et quand
vous avez pas demandé la parole madame
de montrer
j'ai cru que vous aviez demandé tout à
l'heure vous aviez la main donc j'avais
noté dans l'ordre
donc vous passez votre tour
mais il y en a d'autres qui étaient
inscrits avant vous madame au signal
mais donc voilà madame Delmont coraux
police
je voulais juste dire que si on comme je
vais le faire je vais voter l'amendement
de mon collègue Cédric Vial avec le
monument 51 rectifié Équateur qui fait
que du coup toute la métropole pour
n'aura plus le Pass sanitaire et je
voudrais dire en ce qui concerne la le
passe pour les pour les mineurs
c'est vrai que nous avons voté le
au mois de Juin Juillet fin juillet août
une vaccination pour les 12-18 ans mais
on n'est plus du tout dans le même cas
elle ne se justifie plus donc voilà je
vais vous dire que de toute façon j'en
profite pour dire que je vais retirer
mon amendement parce que du coup
il est satisfait par la par le fait que
avec 70% tous les tous les départements
sont
sauf peut-être les départements
d'outre-mer
pardon vous avez retiré que l'amendement
excusez-moi
le 57
merci
Monsieur Hervé
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
dans cette hémicycle à l'instant nous
commençons cette
longue discussion de ces très nombreux
amendements vous faire part de ce qui se
vit dans les territoires monsieur le
ministre et notamment d'une initiative
qui a été soutenue par les trois
sénateurs de la Haute-Savoie si à Noël
Cyril pelva et moi-même qui est une
initiative des élus qui alerte le
gouvernement qui a l'air aussi le
Parlement sur les effets délétères du
Pass sanitaire dans les territoires qui
posent des vraies difficultés dans les
associations dans les entreprises dans
les familles dans le monde médico-social
et je tiens évoqué ici notamment la
question des familles d'adulte
handicapés et confrontés à aujourd'hui à
devoir reprendre à la maison des leurs
enfants alors que eux-mêmes sont très
âgés bref se passe sanitaire
qui était déjà dans le texte de décembre
2020 qui a été voté en avril et qui ne
devait absolument pas être généralisé
qu'il a pourtant été en juillet devait
être une parenthèse devait être voté le
temps d'un été il n'en est rien le pas
sanitaire s'installe dans nos vies dans
nos poches dans notre quotidien et
plusieurs centaines de millions de fois
par jour le Pass sanitaire est contrôlé
dans notre pays et il le sera peut-être
encore pendant de très nombreux mois je
suis très inquiet de cette évolution non
pas de temps par rapport au espace
sanitaire lui-même monsieur le ministre
mais par rapport à l'accoutumance des
Français d'accepter ce contrôle social
sur la base d'éléments sanitaires je
vous assure que en acceptant cela on
continue d'installer dans la tête de nos
compatriotes le fait que la puissance
publique ou des opérateurs privés ont le
droit d'opérer ce contrôle c'est quelque
chose d'extrême pour laquelle j'en
appelle au Sénat pour que nous
supprimions purement et simplement se
passe sanitaire merci chers collègues
Monsieur Arnaud
ce ministre ce Président je voudrais
également porter témoignages
et avoir la possibilité d'échanger avec
vous sur le malaise qui est le mien
aujourd'hui en ayant ce débat en
écoutant chacune et chacun d'entre vous
sur le Pass sanitaire nous étions avec
Fabien Genet avec Bernard Chaumier en
mission aux Antilles il y a quelques
jours la semaine dernière
et la question du Pass sanitaire aux
Antilles et largement au second au
troisième rang la question principale
aux Antilles et la protection de nos
médecins de l'hôpital public et la
protection de la médecine libérale
médecine de ville médecine de campagne
et la difficulté d'atteindre péniblement
45% du parcours vaccinal et la crainte
d'une cinquième vague dévastatrice dans
ces deux départements région d'outre-mer
et j'aimerais entendre le gouvernement
également sur des réponses
opérationnelles pour accompagner nos
compatriotes des Antilles j'ai le
sentiment que les équipes sont esseulées
essorer nous avons également des
difficultés sur la question de la relève
sanitaire des questions ont été posées
en ce sens là je vois monsieur le
ministre que vous opinez non pas du chef
mais vous êtes un négation de ce que je
suis en train de vous dire je ne fais
que vous rendre simplement compte de ce
que nous avons entendu de ce que nous
avons vu et je crois que la négation des
vérités peut être effectivement
dommageable sur une politique équilibrée
entre nos territoires
par ailleurs pour en venir au plan local
il me semble aussi que la question du
Pass sanitaire est une forme
d'accoutumance auquel vient de faire
allusion effectivement Loïc Hervé et il
me semble que dans l'esprit de la
proposition du président Ba qui est de
territorialisé territorisé et intégré
c'est intégrer les différents
territoriales et les efforts fait aussi
par nos concitoyens lorsqu'ils se sont
vaccinés en masse et je crois que la
moindre des choses c'est qu'il faut
accompagner celles et ceux qui ont fait
des efforts afin que nous puissions
effectivement en conséquences limité le
contrôle social le contrôle de l'État
sur la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens je vous remercie merci
Madame kukermann
voilà donc pour ces débats autour de
l'article 1 le premier article de ce
projet de loi elle dit de bien confiant
de ce projet vigilance sanitaire plutôt
c'est des vagues qui ont commencé
aujourd'hui au Sénat avec ce matin et
cet après-midi la discussion générale
puis donc ces échanges autour de
l'article 1er on le voit il y a un débat
sur le taux de vaccination à atteindre
pour lever le Pass sanitaire dans les
dans les départements ce débat sur le
place sanitaire il continue sur
l'antenne de publicaina dans quelques
instants et bien on entendra un débat
dans l'émission sens public présenté par
Thomas Hugues sur ce espace sanitaire
très bonne suite de programme sur Public
Sénat
cette semaine dans les vendredis de
l'histoire le documentaire Karpov
Kasparov deux rois pour une couronne
lorsque commence cette grande bataille
épique entre Kasparov et Kapov l'Union
soviétique est déjà très essoufflé
Kasparov a des états des soutiens au
sein de l'empire soviétique moins
puissant que ce carpoque il a des forces
des Russes préfèrent que ça soit
carpoque qui reste champion du monde ça
c'est clair si j'avais gagné dans la
trentaine partie le match se serait
terminé avec le score de 6 à 0 je ne
l'ai pas gagné j'ai perdu la 32e
je jouais de mieux en mieux et il
perdait son assurance c'est pour ça que
la nomenclature à sportive soviétique a
décidé d'arrêter le match
le continuer le match avec carpov
c'était la lutte entre le monde
soviétique et la nouvelle Russie et
beaucoup de gens l'ont compris comme ça
pour une couronne demain à 22h sur
Public Sénat
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public 90 minutes de
débat et d'analyses notre objectif c'est
de donner du sens à l'actualité de vous
donner des clés de compréhension des
mutations profondes de notre société
avec trois temps forts comme tous les
soirs d'abord le débat d'actu consacré
ce soir à l'extension du passe sanitaire
le Sénat ne veut pas le prolonger
jusqu'en juillet propose un système à
géométrie variable en fonction de la
vaccination dans les départements
explications et réactions juste après
ces titres notre rubrique les électeurs
ont la parole consacrée ce soir au bras
de fer